hello and welcome to iron Lord podcast
episode number 16 and this is part of
the e3 conference prediction series got
some special guests in the building very
excited about this show we got some
Lords in here that we can't wait to
introduce so we're gonna start off with
a lord that was introduced to you from
my man Lord addict and he has been
killing these PlayStation streets he's a
member of the Council podcast game was
that play games he does online fighting
tournaments with the online arcade and
also a proud member of the what's up
playstation combination introducing
boogie downs oh Lord
barri is in the building are we doing
Lord vari yo what is good guys
YouTube everybody that's watching I
definitely appreciate the invite I
definitely appreciate this intro man I'm
listening to this intro I'm all I'm
cheesing right now feeling good about
myself
yo much love everybody here man I
appreciate it man and I can't wait to
start and make and create matter of fact
this movie we bout to do everybody
talked about this PlayStation uh III and
trust me
PlayStation will create a movie whoo
that's what I was the energy I need
great to have you love Ari definitely
and of course we've got a friend of the
round table a round table regular but I
don't actually give him the credit that
he deserves this is a man and as a lord
has actually supported us from the very
beginning and he's out here killing
these destiny two streets and as well as
that a proud new twitch affiliate member
I want to congratulate the man the myth
the night for soloist male lordy boxes a
lot of others are we doing sir I don't
know how to follow that like yours yeah
bar way too high so bring that one down
a little bit
guys like just kind of get more on
twitch this year and I think the
affiliates are getting a little more
reasonable but that was still pretty
awesome to see since I feel like I
hadn't even been doing it as much as I
feel like was deserved but it's pretty
cool and yeah pretty hyped for next week
and III coming up and just we're kind of
in that little bit of a lull like the
start of the year was amazing and now
I've kind of had that little bit of a
downtime so waiting to see what III
brings in dusty to has me jump out of my
chair so can i well yeah we are hive and
again once again congratulations on the
twitch affiliation proud of you I
watched those video anything out there
with those knife falls and all the other
content you do so it's always good to I
think people enjoy the twitch piece of
it cuz they can see the struggles in
between the videos because I don't know
anything perfectly and some people are
like oh this is what it's really like I
was like yeah it's not always perfect
exactly of course nice nice of course we
have the usual suspects at the round
table my man the co-host with the co
most the non agro gamer
Lord addict how we doing sir what's up
you guys Don aggro
I like sarcasm like the sake as I did
and he's sticking to that and I've never
questioned it so you know who my
question you know work on me knows but
yeah just get on to the Sony conference
we got a lot to talk about we'll get
here we get and of course I can no
longer call him the incognito Lord this
guy made himself publicly available our
tech general precise Lord sovereign
showing the public actually that Twitter
account evaluate your hit me up if you
have no it's a lie LP I will answer you
at some point I got a co with a new hit
show for you like I know it's a little
bit I was like announce the something
out of the dark still you know I'll go
back in the cloud and it
daddy don't longer confer of course the
man who defends nothing but the premium
experience the excess gamer we'd love it
o Lord kick is it the building was good
only King how are we doing today what's
going on everybody I'm having a great
time right now is a great time in gaming
um I have a couple of PlayStation games
that I definitely want to get going um
horizon dawn zero dawn and uh my
Nintendo I'm in my Nintendo loved I got
my throwback Nintendo I picked up my
mini so the family is jumping and
getting a chance you know the kids get a
chance to see the old arcade games that
Daddy was playing with a bad jump
buttons oh and a messed up sound like
whoo daddy this is fantastic and he's
seeing my game is skilled because
they're looking at you like whoa crazy
hey you know if we play a switch so we
have here oh the full players switch
going on with the rotation on the fifth
player so it is fantastic right now
actually I really I'm really enjoying
video games right now yeah that's a good
times good time some great games of
course it is Norah Cognito here except
very excited about this show so we don't
go do real quick before we jump in
obviously we know Sony is the topic of
the day but I just wanted to get all the
Lords as far as what have they been
playing so we start with a lord bari
what have you been playing recently
what's been taking up your time I see
you out there destroying the Street
Fighter right now those those dreams of
who they stay yeah I was getting body to
three fight other day cause you know it
is a new character that it just revealed
so his his inputs are much different in
a traditional Street Fighter character
where it's not like a motion or a charge
it's more like what an input and so like
my muscle memory is is a morph emotion
player so I gotta like relearn this
character with the button input kind of
stuff well he's pretty good though but
I'm gonna learn him he's fun I'm gonna
learn him though but it was a struggle
I'm getting to learn but um yes um just
now I just completed a Batman
telltale series I know it took a while
but this completed debt uh I'm playing
Dragon Quest heroes too you know oh yes
I look like I'm less you Dragon Quest
song fan and I also been playing like
Kingdom Hearts um grace Kingdom Hearts 2
you know me but yeah it's been a busy
week oh we just had a chaos kotor to me
yesterday so it was playing that chaos
called a little anime fighting game big
shots everybody that came through um
Henry oh he won the Tour de me this guy
is a monster if you want to go check
that out go check it out my man persona
channel it was that it was it was a the
crazy tournament like people would
definitely came through and it was
definitely fun to be a part of that way
yeah that's pretty nice that's pretty
much it when I'm playing man I kept it
light this week two big nice meme egg
you know Mother's Day got mom's birthday
and stuff the door happy birthday to me
oh sorry duty it's crazy
oh okay yeah that's good that's good
stuff so Lord watches what have you been
clean oh well you know Destiny's always
gonna be in there even until it's
probably up until this week to happen
part of my channel so doing the videos
and knock you messed up felt like you
know this nightfall was not as bad as
last week I was going to pull my hair
last week but it was rust yeah that was
painful but finally knocked it out till
outside of that just still get babbling
a little bit with uh at some point I
still got to finish neo and horizon I
kind of got pulled away once age of
triumph came out and then Zelda so
between those three or four so I'll just
kind of dabble in between those so not
just anything crazy kind of just in that
world of I need to finish the games I
have before I buy anything else yeah I
know it actually very well Louis off
what do we believe uh mostly switch
stuff uh playing I can get a handle on
the NBA playground controls because I
you know I went in with the expectation
that it was just kind of a spiritual
successor to NBA Jam
it's not quite that at first it comes
off like it's not that great but you
have to put in the time and you realize
that it's has own little quirks and
nuances in terms of like you know
release for jump shots and for dunks and
stuff like that so it's not like it's
not quite NBA Jam but it's definitely
good but it takes some getting used to
so I've been messing with that um I
downloaded one of my favorite fighting
games of all time for the switch of the
market Wolves guru market oh hey okay
amazing amazing fighting game that is
powder building okay yes Rock Howard in
the building yes sir
oh that is again playing it mostly on
the TV because the UH the the left joy
Khan isn't the best for for playing on
on the gold so you got a player about
which impro controller so I've been
doing that and I'm also gotten back to
horizon zero dawn so trying to fix to
that is for global problems which you
love joy Khan no no problems would per
say is just not the best for a fighting
game so a Pampanga if I'm playing in a
handheld mode it's really like unless I
take my pro controller with me but
otherwise ogre God she got you Lord Eric
what have you been playing sir
hitman that's all I try to be a team I
my newly was sit down so I can only play
on my brother's xbox and he shares the
digital library of another a completely
other person and out of all the games
that that individual had hitman was only
game I just really wanted to play so
I've been playing that wait for
Microsoft to get they are customer
service in order isn't what's the ironic
good good look at this isn't that is it
isn't that ironic that your Xbox breaks
down they cancel hitman and that's the
only game you play like mostly I brought
this game they separated from uh Square
Enix well actually it's not even that
ironic I didn't pay for him so
thanks migrated from IO and I [ __ ] what
what is it Isis i / io io either a
separate violin I uh they maintain the
IP so they did say season 2 is in
development yeah
I'll tweeted that out come on nice nice
night in the Lord King would have we
been playing well like I said I've been
playing a Nintendo are mini right now
and I have a couple of things like I
ordered three more of them so you know
one for each kid you know so my kids can
actually get a foundation in actual real
gaming and know how to you know get they
timing down and stuff like that don't
get caught up in graphics and get caught
up in gameplay but um what I wanted
because I heard you guys you know you're
live streaming and you're like young
lass reminisce I would like to live
strings donkey Carl jr. I would like to
live stream Donkey Kong jr. so you can
see how nice I am and the skills on
display when I'm playing Donkey Kong one
or when I'm playing our ice climber you
know it's just so much fun with that
many it's such that you know it's
discontinued it really sucks
I really wish they could have gotten
into all the people's hands that really
wanted because I think they could have
sold probably 10 15 million of them but
I know it would have cut in today profit
and the stuff that they wanted to do
with the switch and with this Super NES
mini that's gonna drop on Christmas you
know I want to know if they're gonna do
a game new mini I don't know Lucy yes
it's gonna be the best yeah yeah
everyone loves that GameCube everywhere
I gave you yeah yeah yeah means
subscribe they walked away from that
that money on the table you know by
discontinuing but our yeah hey we have
some questions looks good looks good and
of course me personally I've been off
kind of kind of doing low sovereigns
doing out it's been a big switch week
for me I got NBA playgrounds on a switch
and like most hardest said the learning
curve is is definitely high a st. st.
mph and you got to learn but I've have a
full with it of interlocking packs and
getting plays like a classic on like
Patrick Ewing and Willis Reed and all
these other guys
I think my squat right now is all they
gave me I got old school Dell curry and
I just unlocked Shaq and just for the
record Shaq is Opie Mary oh he's the
only character that has his own
voiceover after every day he's
celebrating tweet me in your face like
he's actually has bogan the only
character Duncan from half-court
shadow to saber interactive those guys
an idiot that exclusively with the Shaq
vocals but um yeah I'm doing that and
then um I just got back into our zelda
shout out the little squat you know he
put me on to some arm things with that
with the hen axes those big sleeping
things I used to avoid and donate to
people that was back in my three hard
days but three hot days she's got a run
man loading boxes girls you can't you
gotta pick your battles wise so yeah I
was I started to a bit on like a Enochs
killing screen but going back to all the
places he terrorized me on the map
you're just you know you can sneak up on
him though right you can sneak up on the
a swappable and walk onto his hand and
here Ellie
my new thing is I put on the ninja
outfit and out scheme or them from a
mountain then I'll glide down onto the
chest problem and then I'm sad this is
too much thing you know you go pause
them right you go pause them and
mid-fight yeah this uh sister stasis
ability stasis yeah I didn't know that
yeah I paused them when they sleep I
sneak up on them start to beat the crap
out of them then I paused them then I
beat the crap out of them some more then
I run around and drop some bombs on them
then I pause them again Lionel's too big
help with the line oh yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah it's been fun so it's been a big a
bit of big switch we can a mario kart
during the week with a shout out Slovak
when yo Sean look I've absolutely been
testing it out every time I get a chance
at work of wife I would sneak in a
couple of reasons so that's been fun
yeah I'll watch Joe I ain't been in any
of these games yet no you you you and
Lord come by to get the Raval that's
another story
some of that Mario Kart action all you
got to get the Audi but it is so much
fun it is the ultimate party game
ultimate shout the leveler chat but we
got to start this off and we got like
things go it's gonna be a big show so
again this is the e3 prediction series
and of course I said we got little
bar-ilan advantage because you wanted
that Sony feel you wanted to true you
know the people who support the brand
also to get in here and give their feel
so we're gonna start it off we basically
we're going to get into okay what do we
think Sony will present at this year's
e3 also what do we personally won so
Lord barring on the floor is yours I'm
gonna give it to you first you our guest
the roundtable what do you think so he's
cooking up and what do you personal one
he totally just disregarded you as the
guest of office yeah I'm just one of the
you he's part of the family like this
isn't that weird but start over to a low
bar
what do you any feeling can't hear me
yeah there we go
sometimes no Apple they don't want to
work with the mics and stuff my bad well
uh something I wanted to do or think
they gonna do I do think that they're
gonna revitalize an old IP um and I
think it's going to be so come that's my
that's my biggest prediction and I know
it's crazy but I just feel like that's
coming there's a lot of you know chatter
going on in the PlayStation nation and I
do think they're gonna revitalize
something and I think it's gonna be so
calm that's just my crazy prediction by
do think we're going to see plenty of
the the first party games that was shown
that we didn't receive a game play off
but we're gonna see it now I'm like
spider-man we see some game play days
gone but I feel like when they show
those games you're gonna get like a more
concrete time off release I'm with that
I do personally think that these games
are coming out 2017 but like even
without me on that
I know I know about feeling wait what
what what's funny is only thing I'm left
for that is you said concrete release
date with Sony and I mean that's like a
oxymoron but Tony Sony definitely
learned a lessons with giving out
release windows and not living up to it
so that's why I asked III didn't really
announce anything like that but I doubt
any of those games were you know what
everybody is predicted in 2018 and 2019
only game I really think that's gonna be
out that long is this arm stranding
that's gonna be out that long okay
where's like it's possibly 2019 or
something you think there's gonna be
game player that's traded this year I
think it's going to be game play they're
gonna have some type of vertical slice I
don't know if it's gonna be like a like
I got a war or horizon type of gameplay
but you're gonna see some type of
aspects of how the game is going to be
played from there um but I do think
we're going to see a lot of first party
stuff but you know they're gonna tackle
the third party but they do have a lot
of deals and stuff there but I'm going
on for the worse a shoe a shoe a
definitely said that this is the year
for the first party studios so that's
what I'm saying that we're definitely
gonna see Dave's gone and we're gonna
see spider-man got a war GranTurismo
2017 and I know you know I know people
going doubt me I've no doubt I say a lot
of people are you know are you talking
about a next step next to you know this
guy's gonna start saying scale bells
coming up replace thank you all I say is
bless your heart based off the words
that Shuhei going from ass the reason
why I'm saying I'm going off his word
because both his doctor 2016 was over he
said that PlayStation 2016 was a year of
hard work but they did drop a lot of
hardware but he said this year is gonna
be the year of the game so it's gonna be
live again from the first party students
coming now we are I would at first half
a year I do think God would be a really
good counter for Scorpio is that
directory icon
my comment let's not go it looks really
it looked really good days going look
really good last year I was very
impressed so Lola Brian um you figure it
you know you say in the release date you
figure those release dates are gonna
drop this year and if you if you do
think they're dropping this year like
what window which you think they would
trap well I think I think spider-man's
probably going to drop like late summer
because okay
like you got you gotta capitalize on the
hype of the movie I think the movie feel
that it would release it like the year
after because you definitely want to
miss some potential sales where I know
spider-man's a huge iconic character but
just having a go coincide with the movie
it don't have to be day and day it could
be like a month after whatever I think I
definitely help capitalize on sales with
that I do think that um days gone is
going to be 2017 that's gonna be
probably summer time and I have a strong
source on that one saying that uh God of
War is the only one that I'm I have like
doubts with 2017 but I feel like that
would be just a much smarter move that's
to mitigate any of any hardware hype and
plus you gotta you gotta break that that
uh that notion that PlayStation is not
dropping any games uh you know in the
holiday season you know you gotta keep
saying that stuff but if you really look
at it I'm not saying that a first party
but if you really look at the games if
you're looking at from an objective
standpoint because everybody if I list
off a game people going oh I don't like
that we're not gonna count that as
exclusive but it is you know me
PlayStation has definitely dropped more
exclusives during the holiday season at
Microsoft it's just those games people
don't look up like oh it's not big or
whatever like that but there's a lot of
Japanese game that came out of holiday
season but that I do not Microsoft
should drop games and the might the
holiday either I do I don't think that
um they need to drop God award there
just to break that mold everybody thinks
that stuff like you're coming here but
now that one is one I'm more Finnick
like you know I'm kind of like that
whenever what I do think it will come
but Gran Turismo might be most you know
probably right after
three of them like that but now our
matching specific ways like what what
personally are you excited for like what
game if they should come out on that
stage and they unveil it or again that
they even previously talked about before
or new IP what would drive you crazy
bleh okay Mike down Sony's want it oh
yeah there's a few stuff for me talk to
me I'm really excited for ninokuni to
know that what stuff I'm gonna I'm gonna
you know lose it a little bit
Final Fantasy the remake oh and actually
guys now you mess with my heart Liberto
don't you say that okay let's throw a
little bit more game clear that the
seven now you talk about the seven that
the one that steeped the part of the
series right they're gonna break up the
original classic Sony one right there
Wow all that yeah they they show that
that would be crazy
and I really I said so calm but I really
want them to bring that resistance I'm a
huge fan of resistance and uh sir I will
lose it I'll definitely lose it with
that nice but yeah man I mean we already
know a lot of games that's coming to
PlayStation you know like Dragon Quest
and all that stuff eleven but it's just
them showing a little bit more for
talking about it I think I would get me
excited because I prop
there's not there's not too many
surprises for me and so on you know they
might drop a surprise but the stuff that
is shown already in different aspects
like different shows like you know
PlayStation experience or whatever
those things I just want to see a little
more of me I'd be happy with that you
know this man games I don't want to buy
no game right now but you know I got too
much but I'm excited man I hey hey this
is gonna be it's gonna be a big one
that's gonna be a big one man lordy
Bartus I want to get you in on this yeah
what are you thinking so you will do
what do you personally
once he wants them to go up there and
talk about destiny for an hour and a
half right of them know why that was
covered believe me so I'm sure they'll
have some showing or some little blip or
some little hidden feature or something
like that it's going to be part of it
but know what I'm actually looking
forward to see what we hear about
those two I said that's a loaded gun
they got waiting about one is basically
just like that is a rocket launcher they
got they it's not your loaded gun like
that's the I mean the first I don't know
when I sat down with that game the first
time played the first 10 minutes of that
game I was just like you know like just
the emotion I took in the first 10
minutes you're not even fighting zombies
just those like damn and if they can get
even close to that again I'm going to be
pretty impressed
so I mean last of those two would be
huge I mean I think you mentioned most
of the games kind of looking through
here Red Dead Redemption - I know these
aren't PlayStation specific but I know
that one's going to be a big one for the
fall as well but yeah you were saying
Final Fantasy 7
that's almost about man yeah I'm not
know is it what they're gonna do with
that I know I might get jumped on for
this but I'd prefer to see a Kingdom
Hearts 3 release date over and over over
a Final Fantasy 7 I wouldn't leave with
that lord ethically from the standpoint
that um we know that Final Fantasy is
coming right affinity yeah so yeah I
would agree if they said something like
what Gina walks yeah I do have a
question with um you know the Last of Us
having such an iconic name from the
first installment of the franchise do
you think it's going to be really really
hard for the second one to live up to
the first one's named for what last of
us absolutely yeah it wasn't there an
argument that technically could have
ended with the first interview yeah
basically it's like the question of like
where do you go with the story because
they wrapped it up pretty dang tight
just to say you know I mean there was
some animosity between the two probably
unspoken but in general yeah you can
left it untouched and it would have been
fine completely by itself so I think I
don't think anyways they can go with a
story I mean there's still a lot of
unanswered questions in the last place
well what they're talking about is it's
not really gonna be an extension of that
same story or you know it's going to be
another person's aspect of inside the
world of The Last of Us
so that's basically it it's not going to
be a direct extension of it because that
was a self-contained story they had a
beginning middle climax and end and it
was really good and the DLC - it was
really good so absolutely
uh not really you know craving for but
nice little joke in there you know we're
all pumped for like neck - right III
played the first one actually just
because it was like there was not a lot
when it came out so I was curious and
the idea behind it for a platformer like
for just kind of a little action
platformer is kind of fun but it's just
way way too narrow like if you had more
control the guy it could be kind of fun
but we'll see and then I was looking
through a list here as well do you guys
remember that preview they did a couple
years ago is for Detroit becoming human
yes yes I want to play that oh I'm back
into that battle were like every choice
matters or whatever you do to be nice
sign in there show the little skip the
tree of all the choice and and stuff and
it kept it kept zooming more and more
out I'm like yo yeah that one I mean
just one of those damn games you could
dive deep in hopefully a lot of replay
value things like that but I mean
they've got at least some stuff on the
table that we've seen before for sure I
know quite a few looks quite a bit
upcoming honestly well but I mean my
biggest one would be I just want to see
I want to get my hands on last of us -
and then of course even before that yeah
mines destiny - so in 43 I'm gonna get
my mean that's gonna be mine so the one
that I really want I'm gonna get it
anyway I don't have any big I'll think
on it if I come up with one that would
be a shocker I guess okay okay all right
Louis what what are we get who wants to
jump in for for the singers I'll just
first go for not added part of me feels
like they're gonna go out there and drop
bombs you know show all these first
party titles I don't think they're gonna
announce a lot of newer IPs
if any because like with these PS X's
like they can show that for later after
that after you know the height for all
these triple-a titles come down but then
another part of me is like with Sony
it's kind of unpredictable mm-hmm I
don't think no uh what would they say
ps5 announced I don't think nothing none
of that's happening to play pro sleep
I'm gonna happen yeah yeah I want also
not to cut your lawn at it I want to
bring that to a lord bongsa low bar
what are you because we talked about
that last I'll pee what do you guys feel
in reference which
to the ps5 rumors that are supposedly
seen any could you trap in 2018 are you
on board with that or not I mean I don't
have a pro yet so it wouldn't bother me
hundred bucks I was like yeah bring it
on I'll spend my money there I actually
wish I knew something that's what you
good all either okay I was like I think
it's I don't know it seems a little
pre-emptive 19 would make a little more
sense for at least to give the whole we
started in 13 so six years even though
they're doing this whole mid console
refresh for sure but I don't know 18
seems really quick I hate and no
temptation you think for for them to try
to steal a narrative back from Microsoft
with a Scorpio impending I mean if they
didn't exactly like they really would
have to take the pro and basically say
both of the things we have our job ever
existed or yeah they would have to
basically kind of fade away the pro and
say okay now we're gonna blow the doors
off of Xbox with something new because
there's no point if they just do a
Scorpio relatively equal and all right
back where we started so I don't know
listen to this in the comment section
saying Killzone VR the order 1887 know
what I was kind of more in total
actually we all love the order well
you're really getting into my list here
and look at continually passive middle
me I kind of say like this year you know
obviously people want new IPs but like
if you look at PlayStation they have a
lot coming down the pipeline that's not
necessarily not going to be at this e3
like you know Detroit you know we might
see that I mean they announced a lot
between last e3 and last of their PSX I
think that they're going to go out there
and I think they're going to stick to no
offense to the PlayStation Arsenal that
they have going with them right now you
know they have marketing days or
something like Red Dead Redemption to
there's not a game besides maybe the
last was two that will kick that off so
like they have the best marketing deals
that's this year can offer I think
they're going to stick to the third
party this list leery
they might go out there and show some
you know days gone game play or I think
they'll stick to games are coming out
this year gameplay that is only going to
be at e3 this year and
PSX that's when they show up the games
you know we we've already went through
the holiday they don't need to show
everything at this III because you know
they're gonna have a PSX and that's
going to be after all the hypes gone for
all these third-party games are dead
redemption - destiny - so that's the
perfect time to go out there and show
you know days gone comes out next year
sure your days gone they're in times
like that but I do feel like you know
we're going to see a pretty lengthy Red
Dead Redemption gameplay we're going to
see you know a little bit on destiny you
know I feel like they're gonna stick to
a lot of the third-party marketing deals
because when you go out and spend like
40 million dollars plus on marketing
bills you tend to use them absolutely
not promote that July you have to
promote that or shadow uh look Louis
moving the building he's throwing out
the order fit into but overall for 2018
looking I want to get you I don't even
you've been chomping at the bit I can
hear let's go also a the book I'll go
into let's put it up to here the list do
you believe this stuff that's right
uh-huh because I told you listen I told
you Sony's coming with these games every
game on that list is official it's
official and you know it's official
because I can hear the heartbeat right
now mmm yeah so this is real so when it
when I showed it right show that list
yes right when they stood up blood-borne
has stuff and prop her up in a wrapper
and all it's a fresh heart racing no no
no no yes the owner of that Mario Kart
they're all set that Mario Kart Crash
Team Racing is coming okay all right all
right
um you know Lord Jabari Lord boss I
don't know if Lord about this is that it
this conversation with Alaric or Jabari
do you think this list is a hundred
percent accurate every list on every
game on this list coming out and one III
ah what's the lace oh it's on the screen
it's a you can't know what uh I missed
it listen listen I will say mine is on
there I'm gonna chime in
I'll put mine in there my team I don't
resort to that one I do want to see um
crash I don't know okay
listen barri he don't fall tell his
worrying trend he has a wording trend
and he always does he wants to sabotage
my segment and I think it's a problem
here but let me let me explain it him
get off all his little rhetoric and all
his little 40 million okay
listen man listen don't fall into his
crap barri this is a I guess is your
first time with him but he worded it
properly for you do you think oh my god
listen the thing is this they're gonna
show these game is some form of fashion
with the question in English code
sir please like if they chose just the
name if they show it on the little if
they throw a sizzle reel up there and
they'd be like Mario crashed in kart
racing if they show just a name then the
list is fish you everything about the
list is official you can't say anything
until after the press conference is over
they could throw how to let's say in any
damn thing but if they throw out a
sizzle reel that doesn't mean the games
have to come out they short out a sizzle
reel and gameplay of scalebound and that
game was cancelled now labarie to
Lloyd's point not to cut you looking I
know everyone can cut you up to his
point on labarie is there like look he
is saying all that has to happen for
them to win the bet we have an internal
bet between the Lord's right Lord take
care of everything the t-shirt is on the
line and basically if everything is
either announced or even if they just
show a five-second sizzle trailer then
they Lord King and Lord sovereign has
won the bet all we need to do is have a
lot I reckon I need have one game not be
on that list and you're gonna lose it
because we already know that the the
call of duty is not chemical warfare no
no no it has to be Call of Duty game
that's semantics that's the man we gonna
give them that I agree with you load bar
technically we could disqualify them
it's not chemical is what rumors going
around that uh that Assassin's Creed
marketing is textbook so I will say that
I think that's true I think that's
today's expository it was on they had it
last
they had it uh what
do you feel about that glory King well
how I feel about the marketing that
doesn't mean that the game is just gonna
be know if sibley it for the mark
Microsoft if Microsoft's doing the
marketing it would not be at Sony's
conference it's gonna tell me that
dissipate this is okay you sure you want
to go with this right dopest system Rigo
and a show in that five seconds a quick
clip of Assassin's Creed because it's
coming out hey named the last time a car
let you search let's remember that
existed by this time Microsoft it's a
day it's a day ahead so Microsoft would
have already had their conference
there's no reason why you couldn't have
a snippet of it it's like what were you
when you have the marketing rights to
these these franchises generally you
don't show them at the the other one
I've never seen it I've never seen one
so we have never paid attention to it
either but this year our eyes is on the
prize so got it moving katti lucky with
your dick thank you back to what I was
saying what I hope that'll be I don't
cut these away though
this oh yeah you'd anyway yeah you can
take it away thank you thank you your
intrusion I do appreciate your intrusion
yet again Lord addict you wanted anyway
um I I want the resistance I like Lord
Bari brought up I really love those
games like like resistance I thought
those games was perfect for them I think
that game is going to come out the games
for this year that I believe that will
come out this year is that Gran Turismo
to have to put it out they can stop
running from Forza all they want it
doesn't matter the game is not gonna be
better than four so just put the game
out already let the people get what they
want um the resistance I think the
resistance will carry well if they
release it at a proper time during this
holiday season I know they're afraid of
the Call of Duty's and stuff like that
to dominate the um the market but they
have to put out that first person that's
theirs
get back to if they type
hello thing arm and SOCOM I don't really
think you know so calm is coming it
would be great if they could but yeah
it's just too many multiplayer games
that dominate that genre that I don't
think that it will it will give a good
return on arm on off the revenue of the
of the game so I don't think so
but my little sleeper game that I
believe that is going to come out for
them
um pop rapid a rapper
welcome back and I think I think
honestly the guy is gonna have a big
presence this year I think so really
okay yep said that I got I'm Rob is that
the the one that you're most passionate
about the one that you that's what you
really look no when it you don't have to
kill like Lord Hawk Nieto called let's
go kognito don't lie it was me you in a
house you gotta a rapper to wrap their
you need enough but that gay was hell
fire it was hilarious like it's so hard
we end that brain anticipate I'm talking
about like okay I'm you know we're
already getting the crash and everything
on it so start digging into crates start
digging into crates baby y'all got
enough stuff to dig in the crates and
let these people get a chance to see
what game started it all like how y'all
how was there was revolutionary and
different aspects of genres and that was
a very revolutionary game at the time
with the music and the rapping and it
was really good so I want them to bring
back the fun in the living room see my
playstation there's no fun there it's a
you know solitary confinement type of
thing yeah so if I can get my kids
involved the family involved while we're
playing and they can look at the
PlayStation as a fun device because they
look at that Nintendo like it's God body
so they look at the Xbox and like here
we can have fun aspects with that but my
playstation it gets no
love in my house so I would really like
for them to get back to the family core
values of games and I think that that's
one game that in that crash team racing
that'd get a poppin okay you going to
finding out Lord song you know they have
arm you know proper rap without not
right now
yeah but not not that one I want a new
one
the popular I'll go to the one that they
was talking about that was supposed to
be in development that they cancelled
like three or four times not to remake
of the first one I know that I got the
first one okay okay
soul awesome even quiet before I get
into yeah before I get into my
predictions just to just to make a point
on what the last thing that Lord King
said actually the the some of the
developers from the original parabola
and a guitar oh man and like VIP ribbon
they're actually coming out with a new
game is kind of like with the action
game is called Project rap rabbit hole
of project rabbit rat it looks like some
crazy cross between some like wu-tang
like like fever dream and like in it and
like at a rhythm game so I know and they
haven't really said who is coming out
for these type of games tend to sort of
lean Sony's ways so that could be
something that if you don't get a proper
- I think maybe that that's something
you can look at um it just a name alone
it sounds interesting so listen let's
oven if that game is there eat we mean
you going in that section
julia savage iolite there's a Kingdom
Hearts 3 playable demo at e3 I don't
care how long the line is I'm getting in
that game I got some stuff like a little
sub to go chop it into bed okay wrong
alright so in terms of software I think
um I think I gotta go with what Lord
Bari was saying where is it basically I
think they're gonna focus a lot on they
do have a lot of third party deals that
they have to promote and obviously
that's that's going to get them um it's
going to get a lot of people hired for
forstuff with destiny and and
battlefront and whatever they have
coming with uh with Red Dead because
what they announcer read that initially
isn't that much but I'm sure if there's
something else in the pipeline we'll
hear about that um in terms of first
party stuff I really I can see god of
war coming out at theaters god of war
days gone um it moves gameplay boom
gameplay so it's a matter of which one
is further along the line mom I would
say got obviously God of War makes more
sense for the holiday season because
that's the known title I'll just smash
you don't want to put I would say it'd
be difficult to put days gone a brand
new IP unproven up against the likes of
a Red Dead or what you don't want it you
don't want to cannibalize your own sales
by putting on a game that's not going to
be able to stand toe-to-toe with these
other big games so I can see God of War
um I can see another trailer for Last of
Us - I don't see gameplay until PSX I
see a gameplay reveal of PSX for Last of
Us - um with spider-man I don't really
see the need to release it um along with
the movie I'll it's not I can see I can
see building off of that hype of the
movie especially if the movie is well
received but I mean spider-man can stand
on its own it which has insomnia
insomnia is in charge of it so it's
almost guaranteed that is gonna be a fun
game to play so it really doesn't matter
that it comes out the important thing is
that it's finished it's tuned but you
don't want to rush that out no I can
sort of see days gone obviously
nothing's going on Detroit become human
um it's they announced I mean against
evil wretched that's David cage games
I'm a big fan of heavy rain um the the
game to follow that I forgot the name of
it I like it as much um but heavy rain
something that I loved on the PS on the
ps3 and I this one looks to expand upon
that more anybody who's a fan of um
until dawn will know that they kind of
undid they they out did David cage so
Eileen Cage is coming for the crown
again with with
I'm human and I can see that as
something ah this kind of released right
in that window right before the holiday
rush um I can see a release date for
part 1 of Final Fantasy 7 2 remake I can
definitely see then um and in terms of
other than we see it so that's in terms
of software that's why I think they're
going it I think they're gonna push hard
with a third-party stuff and then
deselect the select few first parties
that are coming up soon in terms of
hardware it's interesting we talked
about it last week in terms of what I
think they might be able they might do
in terms of a PS 5 and honestly if they
do have something to announce for 2018 I
think they do they mention it whatever
they whatever it may be just mentioning
it I was really a big like might drop
into the show kind of like how Microsoft
did Scorpio at last e3 uh yes they do
have something in tow do you think
that's a legal if they have something in
tow that they're expecting to release by
the end of 2018
absolutely um but then again it's
something is something that ad over the
past week an article came out on digital
foundry talking about you know is it
feasible for them to release something
at the end of 2018 in it and if so what
does that machine look like what what
strength in terms of power what does
that machine look like and don't forget
that Sony is not really against
announcing something years at a time to
day absolutely sure that is true
absolutely not so they could I mean they
could they could announce it in and it's
slated for 2019 who knows I mean they
could definitely do that um but again
what basically the the consensus with
that article was basically saying that
if Marc CERN is to be believed and what
he believes the next generation of a
Playstation he wants it to be kind of
this fundamental paradigm shift then
releasing something in 2018 with the
hardware that's available and what what
they expect to be available and and when
you take into consideration price and
all this stuff it's not anything that is
going to blow the Scorpio out of the
water so at that point does it make
sense to even do that right now based on
time frame and developments for as far
as what's available from a hardware
perspective is that that's what you mean
yeah
like in terms of like going to like rise
in stuff like that because again I don't
think it's feasible and we'll talk about
this later on with the switch and the
tegra stuffing I don't think it's
feasible for them to go with NVIDIA
anymore in terms of consoles if the
consoles purpose is to is to offer bang
for the buck and and and scalable
hardware arm at a lower price as
possible then you don't go with in video
you go with AMD so I don't think so I
think they need to be looking at rise
and stuff and and what they do with that
if they're looking to release something
at the end of 2018 beyond that who knows
no loss no loss of I need that might
drop moment for you personally what
would say well they want to show with
this personally by what either game or
action would they need to take to make
you give it up and say you know what
so you got it uh if they decided to copy
some sort of game pass thing um look
away uh and announced and announced like
some sort of backward compatible
compatibility and of course I'm being
able to change your PSN name that would
be a big change my name uh they're
they're they're they're not gonna do
that they got that PSN thing going on
and they're pushing that um they
invested heavy into streaming Microsoft
routing their routers to different
things my crowd if they would yeah they
download it to the system the system
itself plays the game opposed to you
worrying about streaming Sony are there
aspects their service their money
revenue their streaming is I guess the
big aspect of that stuff so you know
Lord Bari if you want to chime in there
you can get that a lot like P is now
streaming I wanna go I'm gonna go get
the gate for the day
hahaha is that that Wiener chef yeah my
bad I had to step away from it I mean
look at little so good nobody second so
catch me a truth-talker yeah pretty much
a one of lost sovereigns moments he was
saying that what kind of like win it for
him as far as like vacuum you say
backward compatibility if Sony announced
that like true backward compatibility as
opposed to the the guy track streaming
service that Sony has set up right now
and that his second mic job work the
city would be allow the PSA they change
ability okay well I don't think I don't
think we're gonna see backwards
compatibility on ps4 I just don't think
it's something feasible that he can do
not like how Xbox doing it I don't know
cuz ps3 is a different complete
different architecture yeah but the Cell
processor so that's why the reason why
they went the cloud route and I just a
they too invested in Gaikai and all that
stuff I'm so agree backwards
compatibility I don't see that happening
on the ps4 what not appear for when it
comes to all the other thing again
mother not [ __ ] the widget that's pretty
much it which is those two covets that
is for law sovereigns personal Mike
Trapp moments that was it a they do I
mean I'll be cool but you know me like I
think I think backwards compatibility is
a very cool feature to have like in
something that complements the console
but it's a very overrated Dana in much
more more people like buying a console a
new console for me yet having the
ability to play a whole game with it's
gonna be fine I'm not I'm not
I would never knock backwards
compatibility but the whole aspect is to
move forward so you wanna you wanna
bring though so I think I'm getting a
PlayStation my frame so yeah the thing
is I got 500 Xbox 360 games let me just
throw all these games away and get that
Xbox one oh I understand that makes
incredible amount of sense
no I mean it's not it's like like I said
I would never knock I'll never knock it
I think it's a I think it's a great
feature to have
but on
you're getting if you're getting a whole
bunch of new games you know me I'm
getting horizon right mother
I'm getting tails a bit all those games
are you want to play the new games that
you you can get a new experience from
where you gonna go better the whole game
that is the sony aqua is my pit exists
today as as we move forward and it seems
like these sort of we have to remember
that these gaming in general in terms of
evolving technology has slowed down you
don't see these huge leaps that you saw
from the ps2 xbox generation to the 360
ps3 generation the leaps aren't that
huge anymore so that's why these console
manufacturers are looking into these
mid-cycle refresh --is so when you're
talking about you know replacing or
upgrading your console every every three
to maybe four years now instead of that
five to eight year or even most ten year
cadence that we have with the 360 ps3
generation now you're looking at it's a
difficult sell to tell somebody like you
know what i want you to switch up your
console in three years and it's i'm
giving and you're gonna have to forget
about everything you had the past three
years ago so and so I think I'm moving
forward by moving forward this is
something that has to be important even
if access for Lord Bari he doesn't it's
not that important to him I think he as
a for general consumers being a and
these are the each of the people that
the 60 million these are those people I
mean if you think about hardcore gamers
and then the people that make up the
rest of the of that huge number a lot of
those people are looking at a product
that they can purchase and it's going to
be viable for god knows how long
whereas we're more willing to go
purchase something in three years and it
might sting to tell us that you know
what everything you have you've had the
past three years only works on that and
moving forward to running you in my
extent will probably accept that and
just run and roll with those punches the
general consumer is not going to do that
let me think that let me accept this
consume like a video game enthusiasts
that you know somebody or it can be a
casual somebody that's gonna buy a new
console
Xbox one PF for whatever it is you're
gonna buy a new console you are you
already say your Xbox fan or places your
fan you already have that the old
console but you know you're gonna buy a
new console you rather them have
backwards compatibility with would not
offering so many new games or you have a
consistent flow of new games coming to
that I don't think they need to be a
trade-off I think the old games whenever
the older games are going to be they're
ready so it's not gonna be obviously I
want new stuff absolutely but the fact
that you're telling me that I can I can
trade in my old system towards that new
system and those games those games that
I have are still gonna run on the new
hardware he's out but I'm saying I'm
treating it you're trading in your old
system you play the old games that you
already could have played on your whole
system absolutely not but you offer that
if new
he he's a song about world space and
he's just you know it's a space thing
he's just saying the word that we're
going now with with consoles you know we
have this this upgrade system because
we've never had mijin conjurations
besides the fiasco you know the
secretary it's just in this kind of
gaming industry that we're moving
forward to work you know we can
potentially have the new console in five
years that he thinks that it's a
necessity to have backwards
compatibility because in five years you
know you can miss games easily and all
whether I do understand that you know if
you if your gaming enthusiast and you
buy another console but you got to
consider that you know in five years
from now we'll have new generations
getting in the gaming they don't
necessarily have the opportunity to play
older games oh I'll give you my little
thought on it my thought is real estate
under it under the TV um you know you
don't have that many HDMI spots that's
one you don't have all the real estate
under your television as you did back in
the days you know with you know putting
all these systems stacked up because I
have a ton of systems and some of them
some of them are disconnected like my
Neo Geo and stuff like that is
disconnected from the television so my
thing is real estate but if I can swap
out a sister
for the next system and still keep the
same games that I have to play them yeah
because I don't get twisted this Mario
Kart that we playing is not a new game
arm at all and if it was the yet ability
to play the Wii U version of the game
with the same system I'm pretty sure
that people were welcome that uh instead
of you know remastering games are
putting them back out I don't like the
remaster thing this is a cheap form of
backward delete compatibility if you
just have the better or the backward
compatibility as opposed to the
remasters which say that you valued my
dollar you understand because the I paid
for that game I paid $60 for that game
and for you to tell me that that game
can't carry forth into the next
generation
Microsoft aspect of it is they date down
they they fixed it and they understood
that they want your library to travel
with you on every device and that is
huge and it's very understated because
when you can take your old game the same
fun game that we played that Halo and we
can take it we can throw it in and we
can still play it in a new system that's
great that's fantastic because game stop
isn't giving you the value for your good
clear dollar I think it's I think it's
being used too much as a clutch because
it would be a perfect world if it was
you had the backwards compatibility and
you're getting new stuff you know I mean
like me person I'm getting so much new
stuff I don't have time to play any old
stuff er I mean to be honest with you I
do enjoy the 360 backwards compatibility
but I cannot name besides maybe Derek
sexy human revolution I did play that
game from beginning to end or backwards
compatibility
I beat any game some backwards
compatibility like III do get that you
know
I will go jabari a lot of people
especially you know they really do use
that a little bit too much like you know
it's a huge it's a huge you know move
that Microsoft did but it's not to all
be all I think it would have been to all
be off it if it was there on launch
that's what I think it would have been
really effective because I don't know if
you guys
know this but if you go into the when
you load up that 360 emulator if you go
into game chat your actual party you can
be in the party chat on the 360 so you
know there was a lot of people that
didn't have an x-block you know for for
instance me I had the Xbox one like two
months after launch that all my friends
were still on the 360 and I was over
there I had to make new friends like no
like it would have been nice to be able
to go into an emulator of the 360 still
be able to communicate with these
individuals until you're able until
they're able to make that jump but you
know I feel like it was a good move what
they did it was like two years after
launch but talking about unity okay
you got to really look at it in this
word that's a P after Phil all right now
and we lost not talking to terms like
this we talk about Microsoft after Phil
a year one um
you got your Scorpio with all of that
stuff you understand tobacco
compatibility is there from the
beginning and another things remember
that we read that backward compatibility
now in the x1 is just straight-up backup
compatibility you might have a little
bit of improvement on Scorpio you're
talking about true upscaling
to 4k of these 360 games yes you're
talking about you're talking about solid
frame rates across the board any 360
games that have unlocked frame rates are
gonna run at their maximum frame rate
like so whatever improvements you're
seeing on on the one on expert on
backward compatibility you're going to
see even more on the Scorpio and again
another thing we need to realize is that
what's the biggest gaming platform in
the world besides besides mobile it's
not PlayStation is not Xbox it's not an
intensive it's the PC PC and what does
the PC do what does Steam do every game
that you purchase on Steam any any game
that I purchase on Steam back in 2000
whatever itself 2010 will work on my
system today whatever system I have
today wire some patches or whatever but
it's going to work and again so
Microsoft is touting it and people say
like oh they using is a
as obscure as a crutch they're not using
it as a crutch it's just it's a new
concept to console gaming you need to
bring it to the forefront because a
console gamer who's never been exposed
to that on the PC is that is something
alien to them it's something it's not
it's something they haven't seen so yeah
if you're gonna tout that then you got
to bring it to the forefront I don't I
don't think backwards compatibility is
new it that been around you're right but
these kids but it's not going it's not
going around okay and how long did it
last on ps2 before they got real um and
tuned from ps2 to ps3 how long that lot
last year they got rid it he got rid of
it on ps3 because guess what nobody was
using it it was out there wasn't that
nobody was using it they changed the
hardware they change the hardware he the
hardware because they you know they they
have data on all this stuff
they said nobody's using right what the
metrics I mean that the thing is because
I want to stay too long about them I was
gonna say is that the thing is to I know
at least on the on the Xbox side like
there's a metric that we have it's it's
for like most played games and it's on
the Xbox Live Store so surprisingly like
when black ops 2 I remember when you
know people were like complain like why
is that not added you know a lot of
people wanted that as one of the last
games kind of added to the backward
compatibility list and when you look at
the most play games list right now like
it's like number 4 so it to me just
amazed me that people still wanted to
play this old game but I do want to get
lordie boxes in on this cuz I know we
haven't got his opinion on ways that
we're backward compatibility before we
move on and then I'll get my e3 stuff
going glory bunches where are you with
backward compatibility your feeling on
it in general I mean honestly for me I
mean I'm one of those who enjoy
modernized games giving backward
compatibility on Nintendo and I'll be a
happier campus so let's go like three
male that's the whole different problem
but no honestly when it comes to like as
you guys are saying especially for sony
ps3 had that weird architecture going
for it makes it a lot easier if they're
going to do if whenever we get a ps5 ps4
should still be that x86 architecture
show so it should be a lot easier to do
it if they're going to right now as you
guys were saying three to four doesn't
make sense because the Cell processor
weird stuff they're doing what they can
with two but for two
five and in the future should work a lot
more on PC and Xbox the same way it's
all the same architecture they should be
very similar ports that's why people can
do that a lot easier so my idea is going
forward great honestly I've got too much
to play to get my hands on anything old
right now unless it's Nintendo and then
I'll go play old stuff but imported
Super Metroid nematic ampere on my
switch that's all what's funny is
Nintendo is the number one person that
usually backs backwards-compatible look
look at a switch switch don't got it by
anybody buying up some counter annuity
got the whole game let's do the people
but the thing is you're okay well last
week we covered this to user interface
Nintendo's trying to get it right they
don't want to stumble right now they're
on a winning streak and nobody wants
that hot street to end right now for
them so you know the user interface will
start to incorporate all those wonderful
things you guys like for Christmas and
they're coming Christmas Merry Christmas
three stuff for Sony I mean I think the
larger you guys really made some great
points law barring me some amazing
points um if they announced the SoCon
that would be kind of crazy I do agree
with a lot King that I am concerned that
with a game like that or a new IP that
they have basically but one day I gotta
give Sony credit that you do a good job
of not punching up their IPs during the
holiday season and elastin so if they do
something like that as long as it's not
around it like for example like a Call
of Duty you know something like that you
know what and battlefront ugly that's
coming as well that's the next big one
so yeah I mean I expect Sony to
basically promote all the stuff that
they have marketing deals with I expect
a huge destiny to showcase I expect a
huge Call of Duty showcase you know all
the stuff that they have that exclusive
marketing right and then we're gonna see
a lot of that stuff as far as IPs that
can show off that I really personally
excited about I would like to see if
days gone is back on that stage nothing
like the look of it on Detroit man I
mean it says no more like that really
I'm a huge fan of telltale type stuff
and on you know choose your own
adventure and choices affecting game
playing dramatic
and that like it's in that rain very
excited about that I mean now as far as
my crop stuff um I'm surprised the wind
and bring this up on and roundtable
today like this was but what about tooie
threes ago I need my Shenmue man I would
tell y'all right now
I'll tell me for 30 verse none the kick
started like I'm gonna tell you right
now
I mean you pay for it on the Kickstarter
I know I didn't oh that's all I wanted
to know he said I didn't is because one
everything wasn't initially clear in the
beginning and then two I'm like okay
what are y'all really like it wasn't
outlined the specifics into like a
couple of months after when they reached
this gold and it's gonna get this I felt
I felt uncomfortable and you Suzuki's my
man like that's the reason why I got
into gaining Zuki so I got chance to me
so shout out there
Suzuki's on what the whole thing is it's
like you need to give me an outline I'm
not just throwing money at you because I
got my emotion but that's gonna be
starters about throw that money at it
and if it's sticking stick listen I've
seen some horror stories out in these
Kickstarter Street that as much as I
love Shen what as much as Shin Woo's the
I mean the reason why I have to say
Dreamcast I mean looking you it's just
sad when shimmy was announced the only
thing I could think of is what the hell
is Shin Hyuk say no but for real or kill
us up like we know what was at the time
and all I can say is like back then was
at the am two guys would further fight
her like Virtua Fighter was the pinnacle
of graphical fighting at that time right
so you're putting that engine into an
open world where you had to get a job
and it was like a life simulator with
those amazing graphic and then you had
the fighting aspects you know and
shuttle bar a big find that like you
they had QTEs but they also had straight
up fighting segments where you had to do
move lists and you had to get busy so
like it was just as perfect combo
nation like of all these weird things
but just made this amazing game at least
the first one that's the effect I had on
me and with a one for me is I'm old
school
you know Sega guy so like they had a
place where you can go to the arcade and
play the emulated arcade perfect
versions of hang on and outrun Space
Harrier these games are growing so
Shenmue has a special place for me
now if they were to show that and say
released a boom maybe they buzz I wanted
you to have faith you know put your
money on it useful stuff you know crazy
I don't I don't do trailers I don't do I
don't get caught up with them all all
for the Sony fraud I'm saying is I am
less sony has great IP depth great
titles
I am personally not a fan of showing me
a trailer without a release date give me
a date so I say okay in 2018 my
expecting this in 2019 I'm expecting
that then I'm in but when it's the kind
of a wishy-washy and still to this day
we haven't heard a peep from what
where's the progress on Shimon we don't
I don't know what's a weekly update I'm
not on normal bari ruddy boxers anybody
knows like oh I know I know
that I I did support it
I'm a huge ammu fan owe me you get Mori
Lee updates about the game they show how
the story's progressing know the music
and all that stuff
there you go Lord Cognito re labarie
did you put your money down on
Kickstarter uh yeah I did I ain't
talking about update everybody in fair
enough fair enough
yeah what they still slated for 2017 so
come on 2017 oh stop now I'm gonna tell
you this I'm making a proclamation for
the ILP if Shenmue is 2017 I will get my
pro I'll get my Sony Matt I will tell
y'all right now if the
if what lower bar is saying is true
that's how important Sheng was because
up until this day don't get me wrong
horizon zero dawn all that stuff is
amazing my personal emotional connection
is that and the other game would be what
a lot Atticus Final Fantasy Final
Fantasy 7
we got a release date on that cuz again
like to me Sony in its heyday from me as
PlayStation 1 that's me because to me is
like so that represented this young
aggressive Sony they were coming out
they were trying to get that deal with
Nintendo remember to make the scenes
system nintendo turned them down and
they just said you know what we're gonna
do this on our own
and that system for me personally is one
of my know a lot of people disagree
people say it's the ps2 and I get it you
know kids to is fantastic but for me
personally I remember seeing up arcade
perfect tech in one that's the first
time I see me arcade perfect console
translations remember watching mr. C we
like wow like this is Dan see I got my
house like this no dev plus we had extra
stuff you know and they had like jumping
flash and battle arena toshinden like
don't get it quick it you know Xbox is
my preferred platform but you know sorry
I grew up with them and that was mine so
that was just rolling it out oh yeah on
classic what I think I always say this
with a lot of people if you love ps1 if
you love ps2 there's no reason for not
owning a ps4 because all of the games
that was was out that time you're
getting the same type of genres and the
same ties the game right now generation
here's the thing with me levar I caught
my ps4 on launch right I did cause I was
like you know what the potential is
gonna be there at the time when they
drop we learned we all know resolution
gate we know that multiplies were
performing better now me personally all
my friends are on xbox right so there
was no need for me to rush out for the
multiplayer aspect but my thing was just
like okay a lot of their IPs that are
great or single-player IPs
you know what I'm saying mmm-hmm so I
needed something personally for me that
either was from the old generation that
can get me back or like you know
something don't get I guess their IP
just don't personally connect with me
i'm not saying that they're not great
like Last of Us all that stuff's amazing
but I just needed something to grab me
so I I was still okay kind of getting my
eye peas and stuff from Xbox now when
you talk about stuff by God war Shenmue
that stuff that has an emotional
connection me and I'm in you know what
I'm saying so that that's just all it is
but I mean the weight and the way I look
at it right now is that I was going to
get the ps4 Pro when it announced that's
what I was gonna get it back so I saw so
much pot shot loss what but um the
switch came out and of like I'm really
excited about this whole person is that
is you got a switch over a PF 4 I got I
got a switch over ps4 Pro I had the
money in my hand I was in the store and
I got the switch because I looked at a
Nintendo offering me something I can't
get anywhere from a first-party
perspective right and the portability
factor I'm like not even Xbox is doing
that so I'm like it has a unique niche
for me and Xbox has my motor that's the
most why you know I'm with you I'm a
hundred percent well I'm trying to get
your angle here you got this guy's with
anyone right I got a first day when I
got what I got switched up with
yesterday one over the pier for cutting
over stuff that you over the ps4 that
appears for first but it did I had a ps4
already the thing is this which hasn't
offered anything like of a new
experience yet everything is mom not no
disrespect low bar until you play until
the breath of the wild yeah I play Zelda
but that is that's on the Wii U I'm
saying like oh you have to we you okay I
guess yeah I didn't have to eat I never
see I gave up on intent so Nintendo for
me I had the last Nintendo system I was
like any 60 you know Mia came to you
like I didn't mess with Nintendo to my I
walked away from them so all these
experience that you guys like Lord King
have played already these are new to me
I never had a Wii U so it's like the
switch feels like a brand new thing you
understand I'm saying that that's where
my mindset is with not
dissing solely you just like I like what
I'm seeing from Nintendo I like to try
to not be grandpa anymore and modern out
modernize a little bit and to me it's
the portability I'm again I'm going to
go I'm working I'm traveling yeah I
perfect my switch I like the foot but it
is a lackluster console with with a
great game on there that's all it is
yeah that's some girl and I feel you a
comparison I don't look at it as a true
consult I really look at it as a hangout
like me and lost sovereign has had the
discussion before like it's not a I
don't look at it
in the same vein like an extra they
don't even have messaging and polygen me
in the IOP we've talked about useless
enough their UI is so bare-bones and
old-school and arcade I'm which you know
about its I don't even look at it like
that
I look at it so I feel like watching
which which is gonna be perfect like in
the holiday season because then you're
gonna have like a furnace that you
cannot experience anywhere else other
than the switch you know oh oh oh I got
breath - I got Mary Mary oh I got I got
NBA player this lady might sleep or Oh
guys I got what let's be road like this
which is big hits at the moment or on
the would leave the Wii U if you do want
to know absolutely that's right again
but that's me I knew about it but
honestly how many we use out there like
it that it's not that viable of an
argument we're talking about 12 million
we use out there 13 million may 19
really okay
it's a really and how many okay's and
and that's how many how many of those
people who own those we use also we're
not in both switches and I'm saying that
going on the switch I just garden
regardless how you go out it's still on
another platform but is it is but if you
tell me something after sixty million
you know what I mean I'm sorry but if
you tell me is on another platform there
so 60 million uh um they sold 60 million
then I'm like okay fine ice on another
platform like this right it's a hard
argument to make you're talking about
worldwide maybe midnight seem like
most people planning on switch it right
no I mean a lot the reality is a lot of
people you know did not support the view
and you know fell back on it and again
if there's a lot of people that are in
my situation will bar I know where
you're coming from these in your opinion
you like no hizo nada conspiracies
they've been out and I get it but there
are a lot of people who come into my
category where these are words phrases
but I want to get too far off with
Nintendo back to Sony but we believe the
road but over there and we go left but
my bad way no no you burn some great
points then what I want to get back to
what you were saying was oh you get me
back but it's what you got you gotta
show that Shenmue on stage what a
release date you throw that God of War
holiday you know me me you know what a
release date and then if you could put
the cherry on the top
I need that Final Fantasy son you give
me those to me games I'll run out there
and get that Pro I'll be right there
which that's what I need what do you
think what do you think about that low
bar uh I do think you're gonna see those
games
Shenmue will we see that at e3 it's
possible I think if they have something
ready to go from from with updates I've
seen it looked like a part have
something ready to go
um at Sony conference or whatever but I
mean we'll see we'll see
ah but it's still slated if you look it
up go to the Kickstarter they still
slated 2017 said this they still say I'm
counting on you are I'm gonna go for you
for updates you gonna be nice no don't
know if we're gonna come out not a train
that's what they think
you buzz so another audience I need you
to tweet anytime you get it update was
regard
oh you did it since we couldn't act like
like a weekly sometimes oh and since
he's pulling that you need a tweet and
when that's out you need a toy be like
it's out be very right dear Lord bury
what you need to do is tell him to go
and put his money down or Kickstarter he
could get done so that's that was your
opening right there to tell him man to
jump in feet first just like you did
with conviction feet behind the game you
love to go put that $10 down or
Kickstarter hey cut the crap did you put
your Kickstarter what he did
no but I'm not buying it people like
complaints on Kickstarter far like
supporting a sucker some of the games
like you know without their support over
come up but you do get refunded on that
stuff
but that's true yeah I think I saw saw a
Shenmue I was like oh damn
you know III started with Shenmue 2 you
know playing college you know me going
to pee I I didn't have like a xbox or a
Dreamcast like that I was going to
people room and I was clean that [ __ ]
like oh it's pretty good man yeah
amazing for its time I mean all right go
now Scott on on e so easy to me we're
gonna wrap this up it's gonna be it's
gonna be huge I think that um you know
Sony I think people are sleeping on Sony
just in the sense that I'm obviously we
know that the pressures on Microsoft
this year yeah go ahead okay oh oh oh um
on May 16th Sony is releasing something
special I will talk about it in the next
segment okay okay okay we go jump into
video but if you can hold that one's a
little bit well my second okay but yeah
just back to you know wrapping this this
whole thing up first of all great
comments by the Lord's I think this is
gonna be huge for Sony and I said it
would be very interesting to see if they
got some loaded nukes just waiting for
Microsoft to pop off after you know it's
close right Sunday so I'm very very
curious and one thing about something
very good about keeping their leaks
usually under wraps so it will be
interesting to see them so let's move
this thing along let's get into our next
topic and I want to bring this to the
table arm basically in reference to the
video in the Nintendo switch and one
thing that caught my eye was obviously
you know huge stock uptick that Nvidia
has just been breaking you know right
now benefiting because of the success of
the switch you know up to three hundred
four hundred million you know switch
tails next year and it's just
like you know in talking with like more
carboxyl about this and that Tara
excellent chipset that's actually inside
the switch and now that this Gamble has
paid off and you know the switches just
selling like hotcakes you can't find it
you know what do we think what I bring
to the table like what do we think this
happen it's both for the switch in the
future and also because of this success
do we think this would now also empower
our embolden Nvidia to say ok with
future we can make future iterations you
know improve upon what's existing and
continue this development so it's I'm
bringing it to the Lords actually want
to bring it to a bond test cuz I'm he
also has switch as well
Oh what do you think about this these
whole developments within the video the
Tegra process and all the success now as
far as the revenue that's coming in
because of this early success with a
tennis which well I mean when it comes
to obviously the uptick in sales you saw
that Nintendo is going to change their
estimated like production actually
doubled their production which obviously
probably helped with their stock uptick
mm-hmm
since that was coming in I guess I'm
trying to get out what is your question
that you're going for it what a question
is okay now that we see that is
successful and in the video is
definitely problem like profiting off
for it do we think we won do we think
we'll see future iterations of the
switch into if we do you know what are
some things that you may want or that
Nvidia needs to do in reference to you
know like for examination stuff like
that
along that line do you think that will
happen and if so what do you personally
want within these iterations oh man
can I pass it off and come back like I
was like I'm sitting you're trying to
think I'm like that's a big that's a
laundry list or thing take them out so
we can we gotta break on come back look
kinks on with you we'll jump in ISM yeah
I think it's sad that a decision is lost
we talked about switch to but oh
I would like to say that I don't think
Nintendo okay you have to say how does
nintedo Nintendo categorize this and
being the fact that Nintendo is not
categorizing it as a portable system and
in categorizing it as a console first
that has you have to be very fearful in
those words because they're keeping
holding on to their on the 3ds line
because they released another 2d s excel
in July now I already have three of
those on pre-order for the kids so
they're not letting go of that 2d s 3ds
or portable market they're holding on to
that so the switch won't infringe upon
that market at all know how no matter
how successful it is it will only be a
console to them and Nintendo has shown
you from every iteration of a console
system it has been different and they
have used different control schemes to
dictate the console now with the next
console have a Tegra inside I don't know
but will it have the same form factor
and the same playability as a switch I
think not mmm okay do you think that
it's it's gonna be completely different
like right break it down yeah I think
it's I think is isolated console going
from the NES to the Super NES those are
the only two that held those two names
then you went from the Nintendo 64 and
then you went to the Gamecube so out of
all of those systems except for the
first two the control schemes changed
dramatically on the arm the controllers
and the way that the system was to be
marketed to the public so from then on
then you know you got the Wii U you got
the weed then a Wii U and then they
started going into a trend of how the
controller dictated from them Tecna
Tendo 64 at a controller dictated how
you play the games because they wanted
it to be an experience opposed to it
being
you know just the same old thing going
from system to system
to your point Lord King do you think
this is an example of kind of like
because one of the things I hear about
Nintendo a lot is that almost like hello
sobs gonna laugh like they try to
reinvent the wheel for no reason right
yeah like so tells me my point existing
in place right and the trundle feels
they can do hotter but doing something
extra that no one else's I've done so
what do you think it would be a mistake
to tune all that to go from what was
going on no I don't think they will
continue to try to innovate something
else I think I think you know then that
they showed you with the switch if they
if they had that mindset that they
wouldn't try to go forward we wouldn't
have got to switch we wouldn't have
gotten the fact that they said I heard
motion controllers with hectic feedback
with portability and with all that
craziness in the room all that magic it
this happens so to stifle their
creativity and to tell them no you know
listen y'all hit with this stay safe no
Nintendo doesn't play safe Nintendo
plays by their own rules they really
don't care let them do their thing I
will my what you said was the question
was the future Tegra chips do you feel
that the next chips will be inside the
next systems yes I think so because they
did it with IBM with the Gamecube and
the Wii U so I honestly believe so with
the PowerPC architecture I really
believe that they will do so
with the switch because it um it has
been a good marriage so far and
financially I think NVIDIA understands
that they're boxed out with Microsoft
and Sony with these constant refreshed
of the system's AMD has cornered that
market with them as far as you know the
risings and pushing stuff forward so I
think AMD is boxed out with them and the
only foot hole is Nintendo gotcha gotcha
any lords want to jump in on this yeah
like I was like well no one back you
yeah yeah so I'm just gonna do if you
guys the switch dock
what if they started actually upgrade
that and your switch was the same little
an upgrade separately for that to where
you're home playing for bigger Triple A
games and stuff like that might get
support on home and then they can find a
way to scale it down maybe take it with
you right which is kind of says what
they do now because like isn't it
a portable boat oh is it more but I was
like if it could actually maybe or what
if there's games that if you do they
slap something bigger and a separate box
something like that I mean even if they
threw another tiger chip in there
something like that make it a little bit
for your dock but then you hook it up
and you can play some more of your
Triple A games at home on your switch or
something like that I don't know I'd be
curious what they can achieve but more I
want to say remote play more like the
Vita did for ps4 but if you had a little
more powerful base on something like
that where I can literally go pick it up
lay down in bed still play destiny in my
bed you just sign up like right there
I'm done like I am like I can do what
Vita wanted to do and make it pal
sorry I know that this is that what
topic you feel about flee hey that's you
know you asked for but that's why me
that would be that would be the winner
for me because I mean breath a little
wild looks awesome but I mean destiny -
I literally cannot wait to see what that
gameplay looks like because if
especially if they show it on a pro for
example it's gonna look epic I mean if
it looks like horizon crap just I'm done
but something like that - that novel
what hey whatever lit it what addict
laughs at example s of the continued
loading but I mean that's what I would
like to see and then of course just get
on board with the world like iterations
like not even hardware related just
software get on board with party chat
get on board with the world of the rest
of mobile gear Christmas yeah just get
off with all of that stuff that the rest
of the consoles do is like quit living
in your Japanese bubble and literally
talk to each other in games Lords who
thought he always saying that he wants
Xbox to be brought to the switch Xbox
Live service to be Ross didn't come with
lucky and Christmas
lordy Buster's Laura Montes I just want
to say that we've never had a system
that launched in March right here so I
honestly felt that Nintendo could be
said yo we could hold off on this
switched until November we can have the
user interface fantastic at that time
but we have a Scorpio coming out we
don't know how that's going to perform
in the wild and Sony's going to be
releasing these games we have this
window here was unprecedented that we
can actually gain traction and it can
push us through the Christmas and I
thought that was a great gamble but the
user interface won't be all the way
where these other people or have there's
that like you know party chat and stuff
like that stuff that you already know
that it's built for because it has a
headphone jack and they have peripherals
that they sold for it at launch but it
wasn't really ready for it so I thought
the trade-off with them was early
release of implementing the user
interface later on into the system or
late release with full functionality
what is almost like a standard launch so
to speak right looking right yeah yeah
one second soft opening and Zelda
basically if they can ride the coattails
of that until they get like the next big
thing
so I mean Zelda was huge yep so oh it's
over 100% word ops adoption or et that
cracks me up yeah that's crazy right
insane nothing that is good I'll take it
lowly bunch as you get on next I want to
get a solid yet some more points nope
yeah I'm good
that's most of mine give me on PS Vita
since I took yours I'll stop talking now
okay great my great Louis think alike so
good also want to jump in uh yeah I
think I think moving forward I think
they definitely continue to work with
with NVIDIA and whatever the next
integration of the Tegra you know chip
is whatever it is x1 x2 because I kind
of to reiterate what I said earlier and
what uh what Lord King said I think
they're sort of out of luck in terms of
trying to break in with it with
Playstation and uh
an Xbox I think they have a good thing
going with AMD where they can make
significant improvements
system-to-system without breaking the
bank where it
with nvidia it's always the hardware is
always going to be more expensive nvidia
is usually first to come out armed and
most expensive to come out and then rise
it in or AMD comes from behind improves
upon it makes it more efficient and
cheaper it's usually that the cadence
that they did they follow but in terms
of mobile processors and powerful mobile
processors Nvidia in that regard is kind
of the only game in town so I think it
makes perfect sense to continue to
partner with Nintendo because I'm on
their of their own accord the shield
wasn't selling gangbusters and so you
have that affiliation with this company
that now is is is selling immensely
that's that's damn you're saving them
exactly mmm you're doing - I think
whatever they do I think whatever they
do they're gonna stick with them
that said though also kind of
reiterating what Lord King said I don't
think nice something worries me about
Nintendo's they don't they don't know
how to get out of their own way
sometimes well so I I think their desire
to make toys and be toy makers
supersedes their desire to give game
players what they want
I always going to end they always gonna
try to tell you what you want rather
than listen to you and give you what you
want and that's kind of been and I won't
say their downfall but this is the
reason for the peaks and valleys with
them right now we're in a high peak and
with Wii U in a very low Valley so I you
worried that they they that they're
gonna go with that again and say you
know what yeah we're back with we have
mindshare again people are loving us
they gotta love us even more when they
see the next thing that we're gonna give
them it's nothing is nothing like the
big looks all got scared well or what it
didn't worry about you worry about it
because they're gonna need to show
throughout the lifetime of this which
that they're willing to take our
criticisms take it into account and
implement it like like like one who
screwed when you're talking about
Christmas time and all these dudes that
we have on PlayStation or any of these
features that we have on Xbox already
if by Christmas time we have them that
I'm like okay there list
they and and we'll see throughout the
lifetime of the switch if they are
actually listening and that will give me
a better idea of what to expect what to
hope for moving forward alright but then
they you know again I that's the only
thing that worries me that's really the
only thing that annoys me I got you let
me jump in before Lord addict did a
little bar I give it to them I wish you
guys I see what you guys go with this
and historically Lord chaos are you guys
are correct
Nintendo seems to always be to their own
drum and do things their own way so I'm
just hoping like the way I look at the
switches like you've hit a home run
right now right you've got this amazing
tech ride the wave don't be extra the
others they like just do what you got to
do it as far as with the you know with
the Nvidia and all that other stuff it's
just like you know all I got to do you
know in the video right now just make
those those are Tegra trips again I make
that the newest iteration and they
should be fine like I don't really think
they need to do anything completely
different you know as far as just up the
iteration physically of the chipset and
you know let's say two three years down
the road when things advanced so this
way you can try to get a little bit more
of those ports but I mean that's just
really where my mindset is with it and I
think it's a cash guy I just don't want
them to go away from what is successful
what's working but hopefully they stick
to it more
can you give a question real quick yeah
so in the grand scheme of hardware as
well as was sitting here thinking about
AMD is I think about whatever my next
computer is going to be right now all
the rides and processors are obviously
just processors but if they start coming
out with their APU is when they actually
can handle everything in there do you
think that would be something the could
actually rival right or the tiger on the
other side oh that's all drop the right
amount yeah that's no that's true that's
another thing that we need to consider
is that in the PC space they're also
looking to constantly be more efficient
more consumer-friendly more
cost-effective so and smaller
everything's trying to you always trying
to get smaller cooler and faster so um
yeah the idea that they could
step in and a processor a few years down
the line be something that can you know
something kind of akin to the SOC in
which the in the Scorpio and what's in
the ps4 Pro yeah that with all these
things are on one chip and you can put
it on us on a small slab and and have it
in a small form-factor
yeah I think moving forward that's
absolutely another thing is to be
considered that you know a less kind of
Nvidia Shores up this relationship now
yeah aimed II could definitely muscle in
and take over everything because that's
just in case yeah good point but Lord
Baris a little quiet you need feelings
on this video and Nintendo switch
developments and the success of the chip
um yeah I mean I think I didn't intend
oh using the video with the whole mobile
processing and other stuff and having
that concept of the switch was a very
smart idea you know with them because
they already dominate in a handheld
market and you know the switch is a home
console but also extends to a handheld
so people are already familiar with that
stuff so you know it works well with it
um but we'll see how long it goes man
like it calibrated for the wheel to
follow what other there's a lot of
issues with a switch made looks like a
30 to make uh gigabytes of memory you
know all your not lease that people want
and expect
I don't know how Nintendo is gonna it's
gonna get filled up you know I mean
you're gonna be dependent on outside
source to get your memory you know that
so I don't the switch the Fortuner is
alex is a good console I like it a lot
I'm enjoying it but they don't concern
is long-term use like right now like
you're I didn't wait but you don't
you're feeling low Baris that they don't
you don't feel like they're gonna
consistently be able to maintain this
wave over time whatever that is my
concern the long-term distance of how
this this this console is gonna progress
I do feel like the fact that they using
like with like Nvidia and and their
stuff you're gonna see a lot of
iterations of the switch you know I mean
you might see like a year and a half
from now you want to
see a more beefiest which you know I
mean there now what if they give you
that be fierce which would like to Tarot
one Terra memory embedded right listen
please right now everyone play
compatible capability if they all I
think a lot of people's gonna be pissed
because I mean anybody that bought the
switching you know you didn't pay no
$300 you up in the 600 stuff to get
everything you know oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah if they ask that something that
like that right now yeah I think I'll be
upset a little bit but I just feel like
it's going down that path because that's
looking at look at it if updates come to
this console you know thirty two
gigabytes right you know I mean I don't
know how big these updates are going to
be but the things that people want like
party checks you know you know certain
things like you know messaging and all
that stuff that stuff takes up memory so
then now you enter rely on an outside
source of SD cards that's another car
Friday you got to buy but that stuff
you're limited to you know a hundred and
something gigs you know I don't know
like if they want to catch up and keep
up to the modern times with the Xbox and
you know pf4 let's look at those updates
um those updates like three gigs for
gigs five gigs you know I mean that's
that has um I got a I got a question I
got a question cuz I just had a PIFAN II
just sitting there listening to Lord
Bari speak and what he said and what he
said run through with me in three
aspects I don't mean to jump into your
segment not um but it really liked what
you said really struck me and it really
rings true or what Nintendo does as well
Nintendo has shown with successful
systems what they're able to do is give
you memory expansion and rumble packs
and stuff like that to enhance gameplay
now knowing that they have done this in
the past knowing that they can go to
this at any time and they have no
problem with doing so do you think and
Lord of artists brought this up as well
we all know that if you open up your
switch inside the back there's an
expansion port they're already made for
future iterations of the docking system
not the system itself the dock because
Nintendo knows you can always just add a
little click on
boom add extra power and go now what if
they released another Tegra inside of
this docking station more memory another
Tegra to get you up to 4k resolutions
also to give you more memory for the you
know the user interface like you said
voice chat all the stuff are Netflix
Hulu to do all these stuff on the fly
and not to change the system itself but
to add and enhance the system how much
would you think that will be worth to
the game in public now uh to purchase
and it's not something that you have to
purchase but it's something that you can
purchase to enhance your switching
gameplay line I mean I'm Haileybury
stock right now cost like what like $90
I think or 100 it's about nine like so
if you if you're offering like an
enhanced like dock no a separate uh
purchasing thing like when you purchase
the rumble before you remember did you
did you have Nintendo systems back in
the day oh yeah okay so do you remember
that time with a Nintendo 64 that she
was able to put that extra RAM pack
expansion and the same thing with the
controller you was able to purchase the
rumble and slipping inside the
controller in attender 64 uh if
something along those lines were
released and they released them
separately I think was one for the
Donkey Kong and our choice for Jet Set
uh even though they'd be able to run
those games I remember that mm-hmm
mm-hmm
so if they release those you know I you
know $70 $80 or whatever not to say that
they had a already a dock set ready just
you know added on but our sixth existing
existing customers uh how would that go
like how would you think the pricing
would that be and would that be
something that you guys are interested
in mmm I mean lo sabe one jump in
because I gotta have to say no one I
know that idle and I'll add a kilo let
it go please I don't want them to do
extra stuff like that I feel like
you start you know doing that interation
or you can upgrade every year this and
that was like no just you you dug your
grave with the hardware
cymatics that you have now you're gonna
have to keep that you have to take it
out of it because if you start doing
stuff like that you can have certain
games you can only play on the dog
version certain games I can't play on it
you didn't market for anything like that
mmm yeah no not tech to your point load
adding I want to ask you this what about
again you guys are the Nintendo vets I'm
I'm new back on the scene right now
was it yes no I didn't they do
interations know that what better doc
every two years or something like that
what was Mike at that point but like
what about rusty specific readers well
but you to go 3dsxl the new chip
Nintendo 3ds XL they improve the heart
the processor they added that that C
button is kind of acts like a right
analog stick um but then they only
announce two games that actually took
advantage of the front of the extra
power of the system so it was it was
sort of so they sort of wasted money and
putting that in there and and kind of
didn't utilize it so I don't think
Nintendo's not about being wasteful in
terms of money in turn in terms of
putting stuff out it's it's maybe either
they do something across the border they
don't I don't think they put money into
into uh you know optional upgrades I
don't question is do you really think
that was actually like wasted money
because for when the 3d has probably
came out versus what processors they
could put in it for the same value and
have a new way to pitch a quote new 3ds
they can probably just make themselves
some money saying it's a little bit
better some people might go buy an extra
one or a new one thing about the same
price on somebody's dog is about the
same value don't get it wrong people
going to upgrade just to upgrade you
could go out there and say oh we
literally put like one more you know
anything on something you could say
we've made this way last for 15 more
minutes and there will be people so
let's go out there and buy it you up my
battery life I'm good back for the
switch you're good I
but it would be nice as a basis to you
know we'd go a little little further but
I with you which I think at this point
yes that sort of upgrade would make
sense because it's been we're looking at
maybe a year out from when the the new
3dsxl came out so yes but again at that
point when he released it I believe the
system was three I don't move it don't
quote me on that I think it was three
when it came out might have been a
little more um so at that point yeah
it's it's not something that that it's
appealing to the general populace to
come in and say oh it's $300 for this
this new version of this hardware that
you kind of already have already but you
know at this point all we can tell you
is that we have two games that will take
advantage of what it is it's a tough
sell like it was something that same
thing today they can polish it up for
200 and it might matter no sense but
what they're doing now is that they what
they just kind of took the best aspects
of that put it into into what they're
you know the the new 2d s whatever and a
different you know they say kept the
clamshell got rid of the 3d and that's
going to be their final iteration of the
3ds and gonna know hey I mean these are
good points about the lords I mean you
guys all all made tremendous points as
far as iterations positives to it the
negatives to it and you can I almost did
my classic I have no remark for this but
what do you thought talking about dog
did you know chips that increase dog
power like nah that can't let that go
tell ya listen I'm all for it as long as
it's you know two three years into the
cycle you know I think again success and
tremendous right now there's no rush to
it right now but I do hear what the
concerns of like law bar he was saying
because it's like you know obviously
there are some constraints there
inherently that do restrict it so that
in the future if they want to continue
with it you know they may need to do
that the way I just look at it I guess
the reason why boards take time to the
Lord is that I feel they've hit a home
run from a hardware standpoint you know
in comparison what Ivonne's was getting
at my points as far as the Vita was that
one of the things that really frustrated
me with Vida was that you know the lack
of the dual analogs
you know the whole lack of the double
shift buttons
like the switch replicates the
controller push and yeah you can tell
that when you use the switch it doesn't
feel like you're playing a gimmick right
like it literally feels like because
that was my issue with the doesn't only
issue the V I love the Vita my only
issue is that okay if I'm playing them
feet again I don't have the bottom ships
the analogs don't press in as a button
now the switch you allow me to detach
joy Const I can give it to someone and
say hey let's get this two-player game
on right now on the screen flip the back
up tabletop
I think functionality wise it is one of
the best pieces of pure tech I'm a
Penhale standpoint its unmatched so the
way I look at it is you know you've
created a home run here pride this way
like if three to four years down the
road you know make keep that formula you
know you could just enhance something
you don't really need to change the
break and unfortunately I'm scared that
they might do that dosnt bigoted Ted oh
is too smart for their own good but
that's just my concerns I want to bring
that to the table and I think I think
you guys made some valid points but um
if that's everybody's feedback on the
Vidia in the switch and the success of
that we will move on to this art topic
that Lord King has been patiently
waiting to explode yeah I definitely
want to make a remark when he's done
with his old things they don't continue
his stay then he definitely wants to
trip me up
Romeo dust Burger King the real teen who
is yours when Microsoft virtual reality
augmented reality news what is going on
what Microsoft is covered to the table
baby kept bringing it this year they're
bringing their stuff up to the table
Sony has their chance last year and Sony
has done a phenomenal job
shout out to March 16th where they
actually bringing the must own game for
the PlayStation 4 oh lord barri if you
want to jump in here do you know the
game that's coming out for the
PlayStation 4 for the VR and do you have
the VR before I just want
with the work or if I know that far
point oh I'm ready to go man was waiting
for my angel we go get him here we go we
go
listen that was last year III that was
the longest line and that's the only
game I did not get the chance to play
for the PlayStation I know this is the
Microsoft segment but I just want to
give a shout out for the people that
started it first for the home console
sony alright they had the foresight they
went inside and they executed and
brought a fantastic product to the
masses and I really love it I stand
behind it and I hope everybody else in
PlayStation nation which is 60 million
buy it just buy it um four point is the
game that you need for VR for home may
16th pick it up it's in the stores back
to Microsoft all right now thank
yourself is bringing the augmented
reality headsets and the VR to the
forefront and I think they're doing it
at a perfect time I think they're going
to team up with um what was that game
it's not far cry is the game that
everyone uh loves Jesus I'm so amped up
right now I'm so amped up that I I've
been waiting for Microsoft to actually
announce that they're gonna do their VR
and they're doing it right and I'm gonna
do it at a price point that it fits
every Microsoft for Windows 10 game so
it's going to work with your
Scorpio it's gonna work with your Xbox
one it's going to work with your on
Windows 10 and the VR and augmented
reality that they're going for with the
camera on the outside so that you're
able to use augmented reality and VR at
the same time that's unprecedented
that's fantastic and I want to know is
anybody excited about this is this
something that they're looking forward
to as far as from Microsoft or a new way
to game inside your living room
are mad all right I know this is gonna
sound like I'm bashing VR but I'm not I
don't like I don't personally like VR
something I don't like it it's the fact
that like I think it's at this point in
time it's just something I'm not
interested at the moment and I just hope
that they literally like I really don't
want them to dedicate any time at all
OVR at Microsoft's conference I feel
like it'd be a mistake I feel like
they're already there already so so far
behind in you know you know what kind of
games and everything else like the
people who like VR the minority on this
one
you know it's it not nothing against
Lord King because you know he's he's a
huge VR dude this dude played every VR
game at e3 you don't have any lordotic
played and Lord kognito zero you know an
insane is and saying this and this this
is why they can't listen to you because
they will never innovate you know
they're bringing in motion controllers
they're making their own motion
controllers the same way the oculus made
theirs and the same way they've I've
made this they'll bring their own motion
controllers so that's letting you know
100% that they taking this very
seriously they're looking for you attic
they want to convert you they want you
this year to take your time and try it
just try it it's it's not that I'm not
willing to try it it's not that I don't
want Microsoft to bring a VR experience
to their platform it's at this
particular III I don't wanna let you go
cuz like let me row here like you know
VR might be loved by a lot of people but
is hated by a lot of people and I can
guarantee majority do not want to see
anything on Microsoft aid when it comes
to the yard they're already spending a
decent amount of time on Hardware cuz
the Scorpio I don't want to see another
15 20 minutes talking about be our [ __ ]
either
Thanos Baba Spokeo at the damn III
that's what
Oh press conference early and they won't
be able you to twenty-minute that shout
out to normally to check to your point
no that he was saying it's not vrg it's
the augmented reality does that
intersect with a sharp matter here I
already be on God if I don't mix away
the what moment was it was it I want you
know what I'll shut the Minecraft with
their own Halloween awesome yes yeah
what I want any is no reality I want to
see at all
you were in all no reality like you know
if they want to have that on the stage
you show people what's up that's one
thing if they want to come out with like
you know hardware exhibition and show
what Microsoft's have and that's one
thing but this particular III they do
not need the are on that stage at all
don't be on the floor all right start
with you get your yo Joe bashing of the
VR I'm really tired of it when every
game is giving you some type of VR mode
that means that the world is asking for
this maybe you're not asking for it and
maybe you're trying to turn a blind eye
to it but changes happening my friend
and it's happening under your very nose
and you're gonna see on a show really
warm place so far yeah but you know
listen everybody has a throat a 3d
television in the house right now if
they have a 4k television all you gotta
do is go out and buy the glasses stop
being cheap very cheap it's a very
curious or his perspective or Microsoft
VR being that PlayStation as a jumped
into VR space versus console so what do
you feel about these are these rumors I
personally love via I think it's a good
name yes I think more people that don't
like via or doubt it is it's basically
people that don't really like want to
try or haven't tried it I feel like you
know once you once you get in it that
the stuff on I think it's a experience
that you you're gonna love you know me
not everybody's gonna love it but
majority of the people
love it um and if I think VR you know
it's a very slow burn as of right now
but it's only gonna grow and progress
you know me so I think Microsoft
definitely need to you know get their
hands on it just so they won't be like
Sony has that space by all about them so
right now question of are do you you
have the psvr or have you played it or
yeah I have a happy as we are
yes no are so what for what you have cuz
like again I'm kind of I totally hear
where you're coming from as far as that
my question is like what what do you
have you experienced actor resin even
like what it what are your favorite
thing all about it right now
the scares even convince me I'm kind of
like Lord addicts get so got it
scary get listen man the scary games I
personally can't do because that your VR
is very immersive their resolution you
know why because I I played a demo and I
don't know I played I play fish and
experience and I was like oh hell no I
know I really couldn't imagine like
walking into like there's one particular
point and Resident Evil where you walk
up these stairs and that old chick just
hit you into a into a floor into the
floor and the floor collapses if you had
a VR headset on that that might give me
a heart attack
that's called a technician a great a
crazy experience man like like I I'm
more into like the action II you know
shooter stuff like I got like Riggs
raises my favorite thing on it yeah
those eval Curie star but arena comfort
who that little call of duty low jackal
thing is dope oh my god yeah the Batman
to surprisingly that was very very good
it was sure loved that right I love that
I love that and then arm that Sony thing
where they had like the four different
games they had along and iPhone
experience yeah yeah
yeah that was a really good one too
because you was you was the cut you know
like a regular cutscene you put down
your controller let's chill watch it the
cutscenes you are actually interacting
with like if they don't like you if you
want to light a smoke your light in the
smoke with any woman cutscene so it was
like really slow but yeah i do i do feel
microsoft she should get into it man but
like rigs
if i
my favorite thing because I like the
twitch kind of stuff I'm here seasick or
whatever they call it stick with that
stuff like I be I'm in there with Riggs
man but you know you go ahead access
give you away no said no you know it's
like I said I'm not against VR I just
this particular III I feel like
Microsoft as dozen into a certain corner
that I don't think they can they can
afford to do that
I just don't listen I get where you're
coming from I get ways coming from them
I'd like if they are selected based in
like 40 minutes on on VR and squirrel
we're gonna make it at least 30 20
minutes on the score man this is where
you and I have the problem you are you
get out your your times you always
tweeting at all your time person how
would a time issue when the conference's
time oh you know all right listen
what you need to do is you need to stop
trying to dictate what Microsoft's done
- it's like a baby's born
what are you liking it not on that
basketball court on passion oh you can't
see it you can see the Louis what a
vegetable
listen man this baby's gonna be born
whether you like it now you're gonna
need a baby you'll see the baby at this
year's e3 if they'll augmented reality
whether you like it or not and they're
gonna spend two minutes cause you want
to be the time man hey come on no point
to you and it'll pull you up there I
don't know Danny pull you up they don't
understand how you need five minutes and
logically explain what this is it's not
even been announced it's not even been
demonstrated they do not saying that not
you know they they just say just this is
I'm giving a presentation and don't
forget VR and Microsoft are altered with
all our mental reality we have it down
on the showroom floor check that out
thank you
okay never next our show
watching it a lot but people watching it
person there's way more people watching
it on the internet than there's people
watching it right now to load addicts
point though he doesn't make a point
since that VR is a tough thing to
advertise yes but it's so great right
so the experience is so immersive and
then you have a press conference but you
really can't showcase it to its proper
you know les you're physically part of
it that's what I guess for I hope you
know my this is where I'm whittling on
this and I'm really I'm kind of like not
I don't want to hire on VR and I don't
want to hate on AR my whole thing is is
that the way I look at it at the end of
the day it's a peripheral it's something
we'll have to spend money to go get and
to me that's when you break the base
like as much as I much as I didn't like
Don Mattrick and as much as I you know
the whole Xbox one Fiasco the smartest
thing they did even though the price was
you know ridiculous and the rail is
ridiculous for your Xbox one you know
back then is they pack the Kinect in the
Box they forced the hand of the
peripheral you said I'm saying yeah but
it's just like I don't know if you're
already launching a Scorpio right that's
a new hardware adding accessories I like
the fact that it's there for the people
who want to do it I just don't know if
this year is the year for it to succeed
as opposed to you know maybe with the
next systems and then they're kind of
like packed in like for example like a
par-5 or you know whatever the next
iteration after to go up or whatever
then I kind of see like I think you got
a force that adopted option rate because
developers are gonna sit there and say
okay if I put a game on this
realistically is it gonna sell as great
as this experience is you know I mean
and that's where you get that whole
Netflix thing Microsoft paid a plaything
per month to $10 thing but your VR AR
games there and have that one smart rate
yeah it would be smaller I like that I'm
with you on that low key if they if they
did something like that to integrate it
but I just I like that the option is
that I like that they're throwing their
toe in the water
they say okay you have the ability to do
this with Microsoft Scorpio but I have
to grow a lot at it if they come out and
again let's not mistake if I stack too
crazy with time right with this time and
events sometime oh let's go or VR that
is taking time away from games
everyone's got the gun to fill Spencer's
head where our whole games right and I
don't think it would go well I think
from a PR standpoint I don't think it
would go I would never get laughed off
the stage I think they'd be like all you
see they come up with gimmicks they can
experiment with Sony's cuz Sony bringing
to this table I mean you're obviously
they already have a VR in point right
now they're gonna have VR there was a
game in North a blog that no is going to
be there so Microsoft has to come with
the games and they can't wait that's
lesson crazy mark right there there's no
good day for them to bring out the
office party my Sony press conference
they said they they had to bring out the
vo they had to do it it was not a good
time for them the door for you either
but they did it well maybe maybe is not
a good idea in general right no a great
time is everything that money our
movement is this no not me this with I'm
on the move you know why you know why
they need to do it this year because
this year half-life 2 VR is coming and
they could put that on the stage and
they can tell you for every person that
wanted to cry when Shenmue came out
there's a thousand other people that
want to cry for half-life 2 and that's
coming feel so valid blow King but let
me throw this back at you in a chat is
going ham right now the thing I want to
throw back is that okay we can say the
same thing for Kinect in a sense it was
packed in it was none and people didn't
really want it they were like why you
forcing this on us Danza is you're on a
box
it's all about and said about the DM
years right now
a Pinot I don't they connect with a bad
idea but the issue of them forced upon
people it was much different when it
does or to the Pompey it sold 30 million
or 20 me how much whatever right connect
was a success you're right you're right
I want to do 64 stands like a look at
your conversation
listen is innovative I'm widget I'm not
Raul Iran which I guess I'm just
concerned I think this is such an
important show for Microsoft I mean
labarie you guys are out here dominating
as far as the sales as far as Sony you
know you guys do anything you know and
and you got you guys got the way I look
at it is is great of hardware as
Microsoft has Scorpio is great you know
with VR and all the stuff you know so
he's got some guns that they could throw
just a game one the moment they saw it
was to anything Microsoft does that
years and relevant because of the first
one yeah yeah yeah hate me if I talk
about microphone reading it I just go I
don't have the faith in them all with
this e3 conference I think it's gonna be
a good conference but is it gonna be
this mind-blowing conference that
everybody wants no one they need is
gonna be a very you know that's a
regular conference that they
concentrated on Scorpio say I didn't
even what I wanted them to do a pre-show
of the Scorpio so they had to talk about
the Scorpio at e3 so they're already
probably going to spin it know if
they're not going Mac Thursday said it
they're gonna head they're gonna show
sure about or Piatti three what are you
talking about yes they have to cuz
that's silly at this [ __ ] but who'll
just say that they're not gonna do a
pre-show to the show
gonna get it down there got a way to do
a pre-show to the show in a month okay I
read we don't notice my reason why they
gonna have VR there they're gonna have
some type of mention of you to the fact
that they are announcing Scorpio and
talking about it and that's when the
selling points of Scorpio is that high
quality VR or whatever they say right so
man thank you all you have that in your
marketing pitch you're gonna have to
show it
cute little song loaded Monte I need you
guys in this all right let me let me
speak to that all the fact that there
that there probably I defer to Lord a
Cognito and to Lord Lord a ticket that I
don't really think it it should be on
stands but I don't think I'll be but I
think but it will be thank you thank you
oh man what you want I think it will be
in at least some small measure because
well if they come out like this like
Lord King is suggested and they say look
you know it's on the it's on the state
we can't visually tell you how to
experience its our Lord I'm okay nobody
wanting to be let you come check it out
in Boopsie yeah I remember the Scorpio
was announced when the Scorpio was
announced today and they showed that
video necessary oh yeah yeah
fallout 4 vivo I was touted yes yes and
it still being touted so it's remember
fallout VR is amazing I'm the tea leaves
that I'm hearing is that Fallout VR is
the killer app to make people yes I'm
hearing it is apps I've got a lot of
scores on this I've heard it's
absolutely spectacular and again no
ruler I'm not doubting it all of this is
I did is about time spent with this show
tulo Baris point as far as what
Microsoft needs do but most often I cut
you go back in yeah I just think I think
it's gonna be something this day you had
Todd Howard on that video talking about
that last year he's still been touting
it as a it's coming um he specifically
it's coming for Scorpio so if it's ready
it was ready to be shown and Microsoft
has already talked about these headsets
I think I think it it doesn't make sense
that it wouldn't appear at least in some
form of fashion do I think it deserves a
lot of time I think it should be towards
the end after all the games have been
talked about and hopefully at that point
we're satiated with all the the amount
of games they're talking about hopefully
and that that giving us this type of
announcement is not going to make us
feel that they've lessened the the press
conference in terms of the tech though
in terms of the tech I think they have
they're on to something
because what they've touted now is that
we're not specifically developing vor
we're not specifically developing AR
everything is mixed reality and these
headsets that they're touting are in the
three to five hundred dollar range which
is what you're doing when you talk about
the vibe but when you talk about um the
oculus but then these sets are supposed
to be able to do both things which is
that that's a big deal when you're
talking about the D sets when they
initially came out they can only do one
thing and they had a limited amount of
software well now they talk about these
headsets that can do both things for
right around the same price
um and then they're making improvements
to the hardware in that when you're
talking about when you look at when you
look at a VR right now it took about
five and oculus and psvr you put those
headsets on like you look like you're
Weapon X with like a will I get like a
big hitter on and wires coming out all
over the place so I mean gradually these
things are being improved upon so with
these with these Microsoft headsets
you're looking at headsets now that
don't require cameras on the outside of
our cameras for tracking so that's a big
improvement in terms of hand tracking
when it comes to their to their hand
their touch controllers the hand
tracking is now done by your eyes so
this is another thing that's not
requiring and requiring an external
camera so for VR in general I think it's
a it's something that's positive because
it's moving forward and they and if they
talk about it in that regard and then
yeah that's something again that's
something that if they associated well
with what they're doing in terms of
gaming in Scorpio yeah I think it'll be
a cool message I don't think it needs to
be at the forefront but I think it'll be
a definitely a cool message to kind of
supplement hopefully all the positive
things that come out of Scorpio
game-wise hardware wise price-wise
whatever
um but yeah you know if I had my way I
probably would not put it in every day
that's coming anyway love you but if I
very curious its feelings man is this a
can of worms I even want to touch Oh
destiny to PR that's all I'm saying to
you brother go dude yeah again have like
white on rice but I can't uh drawers of
Osiris on VR see I was like what I
like for VR because I played Resident
Evil and VR at a friend's house it's a
really cool experience for me the horror
doesn't bother me actually because I
don't mind those games I enjoy the
experience but it has those oh crap
moments but it also is really funny if
someone has had the room because
everybody else in the room is dead quiet
and then a cat over here touches
something like what is that and they're
like dude it's the cat I'm like well I
don't know that I'm in the game so they
are actually really really cool what I'm
waiting for
is it to for at least Phase two I want
to say psvr to oculus two five two
whatever that next complete iteration is
and if Microsoft the first piece of that
with the mixed AR I literally just leave
it to me what if you could turn your
house into like a horror game boy click
the AR could look around your house and
see okay here's the room build it in the
headset and you can walk down the stairs
see what's there but you're looking at
it completely you're looking at the
Resident Evil mansion but you're walking
around your house if they can ever get
to level crazy that would be the I mean
that's that's the hope for VR and
obviously that's way way way far away
but if they're continuing to improve on
it I'd love to see it so I was like I'm
not opposed to VR I actually like the
idea of it and the more that they can do
in it it's just I think right now
everything is very gimmicky I think
Resident Evil is very is a very cool
experience one of the longer games I
haven't looked at for Farpoint I need to
do that
but in general what I would like to see
I mean hey if market Microsoft touches
on it that just means one more person is
on board more people are behind the idea
of VR which means more people will start
to develop more people or more people
will have the pressure between the
companies to say we have to iterate
because Microsoft is we have to work on
hours the controllers like I just looked
up Playstations not Playstations
Microsoft's controller and then they
said well valve is coming out with their
knuckles controller which is going to be
thing so it's like everybody's working
together so it's like this is one of
those times I'm not an early adopter
consoles a console you can jump on for
it you're probably going to be okay VR
is a strand new thing so I'm just for a
minute let it settle but when it gets
where it needs to be I'm a hundred
percent about it that's not at that
bottom when she loaded monsters that's
that's what I think that second part
what you said is kind of the vein vein I
am to me I just look at it it's into me
allocates in the infancy stage still
yeah and you know again I'm all about
the development nice
what this thing can do and again I'm I'm
all about the development more people
getting on board do I want Microsoft to
jump or they had it absolutely you know
I'm with that I just want to see if this
is the right time that's all that's all
I'm saying
it is the time right now or should be
wait a little bit that's really all I'm
saying about as far as everything you
guys you know saying you know when the
experiences itself I'm not sure Menace
and augmented reality is something
completely different I mean I remember
you know law rule and I 2015 you know
they had the Minecraft and I like the
guy turned his home into a Minecraft
thing but he was you know reading the
blocks you know and it looked at me I'm
okay that's something different I like
where that's going you you're utilizing
your personal environment into that you
know and I once Scorpio to be a place
where they have that option for all this
stuff to be implemented I'm all about
having one bubble burst ER for you I
don't think Scorpio is going to be
powerful enough to do through VR shots
fired
Wow fast I will see oh I have no idea
let's do it up yeah if the playstation
is doing what the level that the place
Anderson is doing and if you could give
me two times or what the PlayStation is
doing and you know this is nothing to
say okay I get something more the tera
fidelity isn't all that I'm with that's
more all in it that's what we're on the
rocks generation so yeah no I know
Scorpios gonna be a beast but I'm still
did you try the five I've actually tried
a mom so they all are pretty cool so oh
okay so you like the fidelity in the
vibe though ya know the vibe is actually
really good I like the crispness of that
one so but that one's sitting there
strap so you know a 1080 so I'll make it
joking I will try VR Eddie three dish
we'll try this again you can fix one try
thank you well very point more I don't
want Microsoft
look I tell you this though I tell Lord
Cognito he has an open invitation to my
house at any time and as a I'm clear we
go there we go as Lord sovereign oh he
came to the house he saw the V all right
there and he saw the fifteen to twenty
games that they have there I support
these guys if you're gonna step out the
box and you're gonna do what you're
gonna do I'm gonna support you because
as an early adopter I want to say that
yeah I was down there ground one I was
with you guys and I see where you made
it and I'm with you now the first game
that is the must-have game for this
system for that VR I'm going to
reiterate it again is on May 16th peace
purchase please go out there try go to
the PlayStation stores or the Best Buy
try the game and once you try it you
need it that's it know which game which
games did you say this to clarify that's
the fall point okay okay gotcha gotcha
so that's what we got it looks like a
everyone's chimed in long everyone's
good on a Microsoft via went a little
bit over we had a lot to talk about and
um great show for the lords and
everybody chat chat was late by the way
I want to give these outro five and get
everyone on the way first of all Lord
Bari it was an absolute pleasure to have
that perspective in the building where
can the fine people find you
yeah man is a pleasure um thanks for the
invite once again um I can see I can see
other going into like huge debates here
about matter you guys could find me on
youtube with Jay Bari I'm a playstation
channel you know what I do I do like to
talk about other aspects because I'm a
person I do like to compare when I try
to make my point so no no um don't bite
my head off of that I use apology from
whatever clear up any underscore bar eyt
uh-uh yeah man if you guys are
interested in fighting games well we run
the online arcade and we have a lot of
money in coming up the next upcoming
online tournament is injustice - OH
anybody want me getting that you can
definitely find out for justice - we do
have out no crime bar real quick matter
cut you is that taking down its Talia
credit checking like it's busy
that's amazing taking it down for sure
just waiting for the game to come out
and then we're gonna set up the toilet
it's only a Playstation thing correct uh
but now is a Playstation thing but we do
like Street Fighter is cross playable PC
the only reason why is not really on
Xbox right now currently I don't have a
xbox and you know just king of is killer
uh what's a killer instinct on Xbox I'm
looking normally when I do issue when I
did have Xbox and I did issue stuff you
know to get together play a lot of
people start running it with those
problems they were good at killing yeah
as we know that's one a play but so I
can learn but you know but currently
right now if a playstation right now but
we're looking to definitely expand in
the later you know months or so so I
always a pleasure man great to have you
and yeah I definitely will check that
channel out especially if yeah I got
that tech and going I'll be heading like
that mean by toe in the water guys don't
plan very soon very soon if coming out
sorry thinking like about Facebook Sue's
well so that's good that's good
thanks guys good and the Lord eat boxes
where can the fine people find you the
newly total Fillion would just say yes
oh my god uh yeah you get on twitch on
Twitter on YouTube it's all the same got
lucky enough had something unique its
EB Ont is he Bonta so gets me on twitch
I'll usually stream in about nightfall
solos that I do if I'm crazy enough
track my head against but I'll also be
playing horizon on they're gonna get
back into some Zelda sand neo destiny to
whatever I'm playing I'm just going to
be streaming it on Twitch nice I always
find me on there and then putting
together all those videos on YouTube as
well so all the supportive on that on
the channel like 7200 subs and still
climbing so it's pretty crazy and so I
yeah I was like I think everybody out
there for the sport so if you want to
look out there and check me out that's
for to find me a nice nice in Lord
addict my brother so not
the Attic show what's going on these
gaming streets
she got cooking this week I should have
a young I should have an attic show on
Microsoft press conference I'm gonna
have kids moved and I don't know who the
second person is going to be yet I'm
going to be doing um a destiny to show
addicts addict spotlight probably it's
on the 22nd whatever day that happens to
fall on I think why have another I know
there are in those podcast before then
but definitely looking out for that and
I definitely remember to subscribe you
know we we do this podcast every every
Sunday at 1:00 p.m. we've been pretty
consistent with the 1:00 p.m. she over
the past couple weeks but definitely do
that uh you know everyone everyone's
information is the description I put
Lord of aunt is loads or Baris in the
description there YouTube Janice
definitely go subscribe to them they're
good content creators yes thank you for
watching the most part let us go get we
got spoiled shows no that was my outro
Alabama bad don't you sad everybody out
thank you sleep but uh yeah shout out to
uh definitely definitely so subscribe we
appreciate the likes and chance for
letting live today Lord sovereign now
the newly non Illuminati Lord sovereign
where can they find you get not five you
can find me now and they can find me on
Xbox Live be exuberant PSN px sovereign
one word and the newly-minted Twitter
account hmm Lord saw IOP sizzling of
course the XS gamer the premium
experience has every VR imaginable know
it okay big fun yeah you can find me on
Facebook Twitter Instagram
what is that Xbox Live and PSN uh the
Xbox 360 lover or one on PSN King David
OTW on Xbox Live the real King David
Twitter um Instagram the same the same
thing with a Facebook um this has been a
very great experience I'd love to see
more PlayStation people and I don't like
to say PlayStation people and Xbox
peoples gamers this is fair gamers
because if you start to listen to us
talk
yeah we're passionate about certain
games but it all comes back to games so
you know more gamers that's what that's
what I want
expect each other side no that's right
yes no Cognito here and like I said it's
the ILP I love podcast the best podcast
you've never heard so we appreciate the
chat appreciate the likes you know all
the guests coming through lower Bari
lordy Qantas as always and Dom yeah man
we got a lot of things cooking while
loving this III prediction series
Nintendo will be up next week and don't
forget to tune in and like I said just
hit that like subscribe share and on
that note we are out peace